[Music]
contagious this world entrepreneurs we
get no value to hate and how they run
homie look what I become
[Music]
okay so today's podcast is a special one
obviously if you've if you've turned on
the TV or you watched Clips on Twitter
Facebook YouTube you have seen these
faces of these two gentlemen who are are
going through an interesting phase right
now as they're coming out as FBI
whistleblowers against a lot of
different things that's going on and so
let me properly introduce them and then
we're going to uh them sharing their
experiences and we'll go into a bunch of
different topics first we have Steve
friend
who is uh not the actor from A Few Good
Men Steve friend is is an FBI agent
since 2014 and recent whistleblower he
grew up in Savannah Georgia he graduated
from University in Notre Dame with a
bachelor's in accounting he transitioned
from business to career and law for law
enforcement in 2009 he was sworn a sworn
police officer in Savannah in Pooler
Georgia for four years before joining
the FBI in 2014 he spent seven years in
the FBI investigating violent crime and
major offenses occurring on Indian
reservations in northeast Nebraska
friend was also a member of the FBI
Omaha SWAT team for five years he
transferred to Daytona Beach in 2021 to
investigate child exploitation human
trafficking and childish sexual abuse
material friend was reassigned to
domestic terrorism case work in October
2021 and he was indefinitely suspended
as an FBI Special Agent following his
whistleblower disclosures in September
2022 and we'll get into that and then we
have Garrett Boyle
uh with one of the best hairdos out
there got to give him credit for that
hair oh boy
I'm sorry yes Garrett O'Boyle uh he is a
Christian a husband a father
indefinitely suspended FBI agent former
police officer infantry veteran of Iraq
and Afghanistan truth Seeker he he's a
special agent was given a new Simon in
September of 2022 in Virginia he was
stationed in Wichita Kansas at the time
so he and his wife sold their home in
August lived in Airbnb for a few weeks
during the time the baby was born then
in an RV for six weeks before finding
rental property in which to live Garrett
then reported to his new assignment in
Virginia on September 26 2022 the FBI
waited until the time to suspend him he
was escorted out and suspended without
pay they intended to close on a home
shortly after which of course fell
through as well because Garrett is still
an employee of the FBI and they have
prohibited him from earning wages that
are more than 7 7 500 dollars per year I
mean even Bernie Sanders will be pissed
off at that right that's like that
doesn't make any sense yeah they did not
allow him to get everything they owned
out of storage in Virginia for six weeks
Garrett's family now with four young
daughters were living out of suitcases
for those six weeks without proper
clothing uh for the weather or even toys
for their children gentlemen thank you
so much for being a guest here on
Peabody podcast thanks for having us so
first of all uh if you don't mind taking
a moment uh and and kind of walking
through the process of you're kind of
sitting there like do we really want to
go through this or not do we really want
to do this I feel like the phase you're
going through is when you want to become
a whistleblower and there's talks that
these guys may be coming on and they may
be sharing stuff they first have to uh
defund you in a way where you don't have
any money let's get these guys to be
broke number two they have to discredit
you they don't know what they're talking
about you're not true whistleblowers
then phase three is demonize you I don't
know if demonizing faces even here
period I don't know what's to come next
to you guys going to be very ugly with
you guys and then at the end if you're
right and your testimony your arguments
and people fighting on your side then
there's Vindication right I think you're
right now in the discredited demonizing
phase that you are but what was the
process you guys went through and saying
look do we want to do this or not and I
know there's a George Hill there's a
Gary shapely and there's a few other uh
folks there as well but maybe walk us
through what made you guys say you know
what I'm doing this I'm not holding back
anymore
go ahead for me it uh it got to a point
where there had been numerous things in
the FBI that I saw over the just the
short time I'd been in it and it boiled
down to a conversation I ended up having
with my wife and I think it was it was
roughly October of 2021
and I said you know this agency truly
isn't uh they truly don't care about
doing the right thing I know that is the
main talking point of the FBI and they
drill into your head Fidelity bravery
and integrity from day one and we see it
on TV shows and everything we're all led
to believe that this institution is
beyond reproach and
it's not it's as simple as that it's not
above reproach they are sinful human
beings just like me just like every
other but then there is malice or hubris
or a goal to strive to promote and those
things aren't often aligned with the
Constitution with the oath we took it's
not aligned with how law enforcement is
supposed to properly function in this
nation and when you start seeing those
things uh it at first for me it was like
maybe that's just a personality Quirk of
that person or that supervisor but then
over time it's it it's repetitive maybe
different instances different things
that occur but
it it starts to build and then there's a
mountain of evidence where there's a lot
of wrongdoing going on
and so I had this conversation with my
wife and I said you know
I don't think uh they want someone like
me uh they don't want someone who's
willing to point out the the errors of
the agency because I had initially this
is one of the smears that that they
tried at the hearing
um where they said oh well you never
went to your chain of command that's or
actually that was in my deposition but
uh that's false uh it started with them
and I made numerous complaints to them
even bringing up Supreme Court case law
bringing up federal statutes even just
simple morality and it was always like
hey yeah maybe that's a good point but
um
nothing ever happened and so
um I talked to my wife and I said I
think I'm going to go to congress with
some of my concerns and I did in in
November and of 2021 is when I first did
that and then uh every time after that
whenever another instance of malfeasance
or areas that I had a reasonable belief
of wrongdoing was occurring I would
recontact Congress and say hey this is a
here's another example here's another
example of what's going wrong in the FBI
and I think Congressman Jordan
um nailed it on the head at the hearing
when he said something to the effect of
they became aware of my whistleblowing
activity in regards to the school board
threat tag and they said we got him
right where we want him he's in the
middle of this transfer if we can get
this guy then nobody else is coming
forward and I truly think that that is
what happened of course I don't know for
sure I'll probably never know because
the FBI won't release any of the
information about why I uh regarding
their investigation into me so they're
making an example out of you is that
what you're saying I believe that's the
case yeah
yeah I have a follow-up but I want to
hear yours as well and then I got a
couple questions for you go for it
I never really had the the thought of
I'm going to become a whistleblower I
I've always has prided myself on being a
professional and and going about my job
the right way and my motto is paint the
fence and I kind of view the mission of
the FBI is a giant fence and if
everybody paints a section of the fence
it's in their yard this whole fence is
going to get painted so I'm going to
focus on what's in front of me control
the controllables and the FBI gives you
specific training on you go to the
Holocaust Memorial Museum you go to the
MLK Memorial and and the point of that
is it's it's drilled into your head that
these type of atrocities and civil
rights violations only happen when law
enforcement is out of control it becomes
a weaponized apparatchik of a
politicized arm of the government or
when good people do nothing correct
correct and uh I had concerns once uh I
was rolled from child pornography
investigations into domestic terrorism
because that initial phone call I
overheard my manager talking to the
higher up and they said child
pornography was not going to be
resourced anymore and I know that's a
significant violation but again paint
the fence I'm a team guy I'm going to
roll into that and it was a very
apparent early on once that happened
that there was just not a lot of work to
do
and eventually when uh when things came
to a head and we were going to be making
these arrests on on subjects I had two
concerns one was the FBI was departing
from the rules and as a professional
when I go to trial I want to make sure
my case is buttoned up I I was taking it
on good faith that those were righteous
prosecutions that I hadn't had a chance
to work the mid bin sort of worked
before my time and I didn't want to be
in a position position on the stand
where I was unprepared and I don't care
about the other cases though they've
been successful so you should be
successful too I'm painting the fence I
want to make sure I'm buttoned up
there's some exculpatory evidence we
need to hand it over to defense because
that's the right way
secondarily we were going to be using a
SWAT team or a large-scale arrest
operations with lots of dozens of agents
and it was for people who were either
accused of misdemeanor crimes or even if
they were accused of felonies that they
had pledged to be cooperative with law
enforcement and I just put myself in the
position of it's easy to Monday Morning
Quarterback Waco or Ruby Ridge and say
well I would I would have said hey guys
this is a mistake I felt like I was that
guy in that situation and I said look
this is going to happen and we have been
lucky so far that nothing has transpired
where there's a risk to our personal
safety or to the subject's personal
safety we can just call this guy on the
phone
and brought that to my supervisors and
uh
immediately became apparent that I was
in over my head because the response
that I got from three levels of
management was you have a really great
reputation and great career ahead of you
are you sure you want to do this
wow so so you know it's it's interesting
I remember
being in the Army and I'm looking at
everybody at the unit I was at to see
where politically they're at and you're
kind of like okay cool and I wasn't a
guy that followed politics but I'm like
okay that's where they're at I don't
even say anything I'm just going to do
my job I'm good to go I'm at 100 as well
and hey this is what I'm going to be
doing I'm good to go all right then you
get out of the army and you're working
at a environment where in the company I
was a part of a nearly 50 percent of
guys I work with were LDS so there were
Mormons and I'm learning about hey you
know Gordon B Hinckley and and these
their virtues and this is this and you
know here's what's going on in Utah and
I'm looking cool I respect this is what
these guys are doing no problem I go to
Harvard for a business program
and it was at the same time when Hillary
Clinton and Clinton and Trump had their
first debate and the the one where you'd
be in jail I don't know whichever ones
it's either the first or second I don't
know which one it was because you'd be
in jail right not the best we're
watching this at the chow hall chow hall
is not the military child hall because
that's what I thought it was spelled
chow hall is a man's name called ciao
and Hall so I was so confused you
understand what I'm saying I literally
go Harvard you'll see it's a guy that's
a very can you can you Google or Harvard
child Hall please it's a very wealthy
man in Harvard the building is called
the chow hall so all the military guys
were like you got me waiting for some
some you know ghetto food with whatever
but no it's actually fantastic so funny
so we're watching the debate and I'm
sitting quietly on the sideline this is
eight years ago and I'm watching I'm
like every when I tell you 99
of the people were rooting for Hillary
at Harvard which is a institution of
thinking and you know it's advancement
and you got critical thinking nope 99
and every time Trump got her boo boo and
I'm like wow yeah this is this is pretty
ridiculous I like a good debate you guys
are all on one side this is not a
university this is a [__] show year
right
so but eventually you do one of two
things when you're in an environment
like that you either sit there and you
say well I better not say anything
because I know where these guys stand or
you sit there and you risk saying
something and if you do you're going to
create a lot of enemies did you both
have a moment like that where you're
sitting there saying well I kind of know
every one of these guys are they hate
Trump every one of these guys can't
stand Republicans every one of these
guys I better not say anything and try
to be as level-headed as possible on my
argument or you're like no everybody
knew what we stood and I still get my
argument what was it like for me where I
was in Wichita I'd say most of the
people there
um we were reasonably minded people but
it boiled down to so there's a passage
in the Bible in Ephesians Ephesians uh
where it talks about the armor of God
and a key theme of that is standing firm
and that means standing firmer in your
faith against the schemes of the devil
and standing firm for the truth
and you mentioned it it's not easy it
has not been easy you can only imagine
and it it I'm sure it will get hard
again I'm sure
um the spiritual forces at work are
mounting and attack and I'm certain the
FBI is mounting some type of attack on
me and Steve and others for speaking out
because the like you said about Harvard
the institutional rot it is it's it's
everywhere it has been infiltrated
everywhere and so I wouldn't say it was
like a watershed moment of like
not this is the hill you know I think I
think that the hill is picked for us and
we just have to obey the Supreme
Commander uh Christ and if we don't do
that then then we will have to account
for that at the end and
uh so it was more for me it was more of
that aspect and then
locally in Wichita it was I would bet
most of the people there agree with me
about most of these things for instance
the school board threat tag my boss
himself when that threat tag came out
came to my squad because I've worked
jttf so and it was a criminal and a ctd
criminal terrorism division uh tartag he
straight up said to us we will not be
going to school board meetings on the
squad now we never got tasked with
actually having to do that so my
question is if the pressure came from
above because in the FBI that's my
stance is that HQ level senior staff
executive staff level that is where the
institutional route is is the worst and
the and the headquarters level that's
where it's the worst so if that pressure
came down from above
um would he have stood firm on that
um belief that we wouldn't go to those
school board meetings I don't know
um because I'm pretty sure Steve was one
of the agents who was ordered to go to
one of those school board meetings yep
Yeah we actually surveilled a subject a
January 6 subject we were told that he
was going to be going to a school board
meeting uh that was going to be expected
to be kind of Rowdy there was some
pornographic material that was
discovered in the school library so a
lot of parents were going to it and it
was sort of clear to me at that point
that there was there was an attempt to
marry January 6 domestic terrorism to
school boards we wound up going to the
parking lot and watching this guy and
and we were attempting to document
anybody who we was meeting with to get
their license plates and and that's just
another Downstream uh collateral damage
effect of this growing domestic
intelligence agency that the FBI has
sort of evolved into but to the original
question for me just sitting in the room
with these people
um I felt like I had conviction about
what I believed and no man can serve two
masters
they were attempting to please their
higher-ups because their ambition and
their passion for the FBI is to promote
that's that's really what it is once you
get into those management not leadership
management ranks within the FBI promote
from within promote and it's a very
systematic process where it's every 18
months you need to be filling out your
resume and doing it in a certain way
pleasing the right people to go to the
next role so they're never actually
doing the job they want to do their job
in their mind is get to the next job
so they just didn't have the conviction
that I had where I say
this is not an easy decision but it's
simple
and when I was bringing my concerns to
them they were some of them were
genuinely perplexed that I would put
this out there to them when I could just
simply do what I was told there there
were some True Believers in my my
special agent in charge she certainly
used some Choice words with me she
called me a conspiracy theorist and she
said that I represented a fringe belief
and that I couldn't possibly understand
anything that happened on January 6
because I wasn't there but she was there
on the seventh floor which is FBI
internal code speak if you say the
seventh floor that means the the FBI
director means you're an important
person by proxy so she said I was on the
seventh floor that day that those people
tried to seize our democracy
and that phrase that language choice to
me says that she's really a True
Believer and that was in keeping with
things that she had done we're we're now
in the uh the Blessed month of of June
here and uh she put up a gay pride flag
display in our in our office in
Jacksonville and after the the Dobbs
decision was uh rendered she put an
email out talking about women's rights
potentially being lost so definitely uh
was not hiding her her left politics
um uh first of all I want to thank both
of you guys for your service both law
enforcement and Military me and Pat are
both veterans and I I saw the entire
hearing last night we flew in from Texas
and it was not only embarrassing it was
disgusting just to see how from
everything you guys have done it takes
one second I think it was you gear you
said that you sworn you didn't swear an
oath to the FBI you guys swore an oath
to the Constitution of the United States
which states all enemies foreign and
domestic this is the domestic that's
them that's the domestic so I want to
ask you guys a question in regards to
January 6th I I think I read something
that they didn't want to lump everybody
in just as one case they did it
individually so these people when they
went home they could go after them in
all these states to make it seem like
white supremacy and this terrorism was
widespread is that one of the directives
that they told you guys that that that's
my wish and blur complaint that's it
right there they said you let them go
home and then we'll get them
individually so we can make this whole
January 6th it's not just it wasn't just
this one event it was Across the Nation
yeah it's the the way the FBI rule book
says is if the offense occurs in a
location you're supposed to open it in
that location and investigate it you can
do what they did which was they opened a
separate case for every single person
assign them to the areas where they
lived for logistical purposes however
once that decision is made and it's very
dubious that they made that decision
yeah it's it's very clear that they're
juking the stats of course but it's
still allowable where they then departed
from the rules it's definitely a
departure is they stood up a task force
in Washington DC which was giving
directives to the agents in the field
who on paper were supposed to be in
charge of those cases so there was a
situation and I expressed this to my
bosses I could go on the stand and the
defense attorney will say agent friend
did you do anything in your case did you
make any decisions and I would have to
honestly say no I didn't and then that
puts the federal prosecutor position
where he has to impeach me and we could
be in trouble and we could have a guy
who was doing something legitimately
wrong walk on that it has nothing to do
with January 6. it has something to do
with the process and then this just
represented the largest most egregious
example of what the FBI does with
Statistics pertaining to domestic
terrorism and all across the board I
mean it's all a numbers game and I'm
sure you'll appreciate this this is
something that's been around for 10
years it's called integrated program
management
and this is a metric system think of it
as the traffic cops got to write his
ticket quota the FBI uh implemented
about a decade ago no surprise domestic
terrorism numbers have quadrupled in 10
years and it is not only tied to funding
requests from from Congress for the
agency it is tied to executive
compensation senior executive service
members get somewhere between Thirty and
fifty thousand dollars because their
subordinates are able to open up a
certain number of cases use certain
tools so Garrett can speak to this
you're pressured to open up a wiretap
the most invasive investigative tool
legitimate tool but you're pressured to
because we have to have at least one
wiretap this year so boss can get his
bonus does fisa warrants fall into that
too they do files of warrants under that
it's like if you do if you put a warrant
on somebody they're like you've got a
Bonus like is that insane yeah so a
Title II wiretap and a fisa uh our what
the FBI considers sophisticated
techniques it's part of this IPM
structure that Steve was talking about
and it's it's part of the metrics that
they have to meet every field office has
to meet and it's it's basically a check
mark system red bad you didn't meet the
standard green you met what you set out
to do gold you exceeded so say for any
given year the Kansas City field office
says hey we need to get three wiretaps
or of either sort fisa or title three
so of course that pressure is going to
then trickle down onto the people doing
the actual work because the boss wants
to get that that gold check mark so you
get that bonus and and it's especially
in law enforcement in the alleged Land
of the Free you have a system in place
where you're giving a monetary bonus for
law enforcement work that is not how the
scales of Justice are supposed to tip
because
in law enforcement you seek the facts
you find this the as many facts as you
can because that is going to get you as
close to the truth as possible with any
given case you may not ever know the
entire full truth but you can get close
enough and well that's why we have a
court system and and a different
standards of
um you know you have Reasonable
Suspicion and probable cause and Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt and all these things
uh because you may never get 100 of the
truth but when you have the highest
ranking member in any field office
really in in the Forefront of their mind
thinking man I know I have a really nice
SES salary but I can get that bonus
bumped up even more if if we can get a
lot of these sophisticated techniques or
numbers of arrests or whatever and it's
like that's that's not how law
enforcement is supposed to work that's
how sales works right because sales team
is like who determines that comp plan
who created that comp plan 10 years ago
the federal government oh the the IPM
structure I'm not sure but there is a
federal statute across all federal
government for all SES employees but who
created that content incentive who who
led it it's FBI it's all it's all across
the FBI it's all across the board all
across every every federal government
institution it had to be the government
it was an outside Consulting I don't
know if it was McKinsey or somebody like
that that they brought in I I believe it
was actually multiple Consulting
companies kind of came up on this system
and it's it's not even just opening up
in a certain number of cases in using
certain number of tools and then you
start playing the sales game of I've had
situations where I was told hey we
already hit our numbers for this year we
don't want to exceed them too much
because then we're going to have to hit
higher numbers next year can you delay
indicting that case for a couple months
till the new fiscal year and by the way
I can see that happening because in
sales it's called sandbagging so what
what that means is say you have end of
the month you already beat everybody but
you got 28 deals you can wait and hang
on to for five days to report on the
first of the next month to start off
strong and you've already hit your
bonuses for the month so you send back
but that's in business and sales if
there's anywhere there shouldn't be
sandbag in is the FBI well you're
putting the public at risk of Fraud and
Force and and I think it would be
interesting and I've never done this but
now that you've mentioned that
um maybe do a statistical analysis of
how many cases get brought in the first
week of October interesting wow yeah
Q4 is what you're saying that's right
that's fiscal year rules over September
30th to October 1 is a new fiscal year
yeah I wonder how many search warrants
get loaded up on October 1st 2nd and 3rd
just because those squads are saying
we're holding this back and then at the
first possible moment because and
they're at their core they're still cops
they want to go get the bad guy and then
they just unleash at that point that's
actually a great point I doubt the FBI
would ever release that information but
I'm sure Steve can attest to that well
anybody who work who's worked in
government at the end of the fiscal year
what happens hey we got this much money
left we got to spend it spend it spend
spend it or we're not going to get it
next year there's a few things I would
want to know and Adam I'm going to say
this and then I'm going to come too so I
think you want to say something there's
a few things I want to know uh you know
the data data that shows for every
conservative Professor there's 11 to 13
liberals in College University it's
great it's good for us to know that and
in the stat that says for every you know
out of a hundred teachers K through 12
and public schools 97 of them in English
English teachers 97 out of 100 teachers
gave to democratic party three gave to a
Republican and then go to health
teachers K-12 it's 98 to 2 and then if
you do math and science it's 87 to 13
right where we know at least Math and
Science 87 are Democrats 13 are
Republicans conservatives great what
percentage of FBI as a whole would you
say are Democrats or Republicans or
independents
that that's a tough one to put as a
whole because there's some great
divisions within the FBI so there's
about 40 000 employees in the FBI only
14 000 are special agents so the
majority of the population is support
staff
um it's different culturally for support
staff I think they tend to lean and
especially in the intelligence analysis
field they tend to lean left those are
the people that are writing essentially
their profession is writing College term
papers and they're very over-educated
College mindset so that that and you've
seen like that Richmond field office a
radical traditional catholic memo came
out from an intelligence analyst
definitely only using left-wing sources
on that as far as the administrative
staff goes I never really dug into
politics with too many of them I think
from the the agent population then you
also have to split between the rank and
file boots on the ground guys that just
want to be cops and and they tend to be
moderate to conservative uh I think that
that's it's gun culture I mean you're
obviously the Second Amendment comes in
and that's going to be a good guide a
Plumb line for politics and if you're
comfortable carrying a gun you probably
support Second Amendment you're probably
conservative but the management
structure is left-leaning and I I
attribute that to the the way that that
process works it's very self-selecting
because in order to become a manager in
the FBI you have to be one to be willing
to go back and forth to Washington DC
all the time Family Roots aren't there
secondly you have to initiate something
that is new and novel uh do something
with a splash to put on your resume and
the nature of a conservative person is
what do I what's the waste Fraud and
Abuse that I can cut and just do the job
sure the person who's left leaning is
not opposed to a new initiative and
that's where you know I made the
comparison to the uh the the movie
Jurassic world where Vincent d'onofrio's
character wants to use the Velociraptors
to go after terrorists and and it's it's
funny but it's it's true because it
briefs well you put it on a PowerPoint
we don't need a drone strike we've done
that I can't promote off a drone strike
or send an unseal team I'll use
Velociraptors and that's how somebody
would promote within the military and
within the FBI is it a similar structure
like when you're in the Bible if you're
watching this and you're enjoying and
you want more you want to hear more from
what these gentlemen have to say in a
long form podcast where they can talk
freely it's about them today it's not
about us but if you give it a thumbs up
subscribe to Channel and share it so
other people can see it as well we've
grown quickly to 10 000 people live
watching it right now
I think more and more people need to
hear what these gentlemen have to say in
the middle in the military you know how
uh uh hhc or headquarters would look at
field they would look at grunts like
you're you're dumb you just carry a gun
and I'm an officer my my boots are
always shine and clean look how dirty
your boots are you know I'm always I got
my stuff from you know Quartermasters I
got my crease everything you look like
you know dirt you don't look good you
don't do this there was a certain like
I'm smarter than you I'm better than you
and then when you would say yes sir to
enlisted they're like hey don't don't
tell me that I work for a living is is
it that kind of a mindset where the guys
at that level think you guys are just
just listen go do the work but we're
gonna tell you what to do is it kind of
like that kind of a culture yeah okay
you know because I can speak to the Army
side of things too very similar
experience I had a couple really good
officers
um but by and large that type of hubris
it's it has infected the FBI at the
senior management levels
yeah that's a problem when that happens
because when it's a top-down and and the
guys are doing the work and by the way
you both worked under Comey and you
worked on the ray right I was just under
Ray you were just underrate okay so you
got involved what year when when 2018 I
got hired 2018. so he's 2017 August I
think is when he came in and right
before that was Comey for whatever four
years he was in how different was it was
there was there a immediate feel
of a different in culture under Comey
array or no you don't feel nothing it
was the same thing well I I didn't
really feel it I was in a small office
but I do think that there was a cultural
change that happened and we were talking
about this actually earlier
um after September 11th when Bob Mueller
became the FBI director and the
transition to the intelligence agency
that you now see through its full
fruition began and the people that came
in uh under Mueller in the early days
they're now in a position of leadership
in the FBI so they came in it's very
Patriot Act neocon mindset that maybe
inspired them to join then Comey comes
in and he brought in the I'm ethical
beyond all reproach and and unethical I
I am ethical and I I I think the story
is that the his lieutenants and the
folks that were around him and are now
ascending these very high levels they
were called the College of cardinals
because they are True Believers in their
utmost morality you cannot question
they've never looked in the mirror and
said am I the bad guy and now they are
the executive assistant director what an
arrogant way of doing things oh my God
that's disgusting I've been around
people like that I've never met anybody
that's you know there's people like that
in church there's people like that in
schools there's people like that
everywhere and they're very annoying to
work for and work with and there's
there's a big gap also in their
experience on on the ground with people
so take Jennifer more she's just about
to retire at the executive assistant
director uh she's been the FBI since the
mid 90s she came in before uh her time
she was not an agent she was a support
staff and then eventually became an
agent she worked FBI cases from 1999 to
2005. in a 30-year career six of them
were spent actually doing the
investigative work that she is now
having this managerial responsibility of
overseeing and I think that that just
leads to a tremendous disconnect between
the the management class and the rank
and file I I want to get back to this
concept of being a whistleblower right
so the definition of whistleblower is a
whistle whistleblower protection act of
1989 the law protects federal employees
who disclose evidence of waste
fraud or abuse which you know you guys
are doing all right under this act
federal employees are protected from
retaliation
uh when they disclose information that
they are reasonably believe shows
evidence of Rogue doing all right cool
so when I think of the concept of a
whistleblower in simple terms it's
almost like a referee like the referee
in sports I'm a big Sports guy your job
is not to root from one particular team
your job is to basically call balls and
Strikes blow the whistle uh when you see
a foul and and let the game uh be played
out so the nature of the the job of the
FBI as to what investigate crimes defend
the Homeland
um uh defend against National Security
threats right not supposed to be
apolitical no ideology whatsoever just
blow the whistle balls and Strikes be
the referee so when you think of
whistleblowers over the last decade or
so who comes to mind Edward Snowden he
blew the whistle on the overreach after
the Patriot Act and basically uh the
mass National surveillance that was
going on on a global scale everything
with Julia Assange Wikileaks Chelsea
Manning everything happened with that I
mean the most famous whistleblower was
deep throat right with um Mark esper
with uh the Nixon the Watergate
situation so in simple terms I'm just
kind of framing this for you guys in
simple terms when they look back at what
you guys have done when people tell your
story uh what are you blowing the
whistle on exactly
so there's been a handful of things for
me
um
one of the main ones that I that I like
to talk about we've touched on a little
bit is the stat padding so
because Steve said in the last decade
domestic terrorism stats have gone up
400 percent well I have an example
proving just that so I had a case it was
technically one case but the FBI had me
open up four cases because there were
four individuals involved who are all
part of the same group so if you
multiply that across all field offices
you know in my individual example it's a
400 increase but
multiply that across and it's like it
shows this picture to America that
there's this huge domestic terrorism
problem the January 6 example that Steve
has is another example of that because
then every field office is opening all
these separate cases and and then the
FBI can say look we really do have this
huge domestic terrorism problem when in
actuality it's not really uh showing the
the whole truth or the real facts of
what's going on we talked about the
school board threat tag that was another
one for me
um that I blew the whistle on and then
uh another threat tag it was uh threats
to scotus 2022 that was shortly after
the Hobbs decision came down reversing
row which in that instance the left were
the ones who were up in arms you know
protesting outside of Supreme Court
Justices homes which is a federal crime
which to my knowledge even to to right
now no one has been charged with that
um but when the FBI sent out that threat
tag part of the information was
to focus on people who have a pro-life
ideology and again my boss was the one
who brought this threat tag to my
attention and he said you know part of
the guidance says to to dig into
pro-life people why would we do that
they're going to be happy about this
they're not going to be attacking
anybody and this threat tag is supposed
to be about protecting Supreme Court
Justices not about you know some some
firebombing attack on a on an abortion
clinic which also
if you're pro-life you're not going to
attack at that moment because you're
counting that as a win and then
um what multiplied that for me which is
why I blew the whistle on it is then I
got tasked with
um questioning a CHS of mine which is
what the FBI calls a confidential human
source so that's in common parlance it's
a CI a confidential informant and so
in that one I was like okay we just got
this threat tag now I just get this
tasking to go talk to this guy and even
him when I asked him these questions he
was like why are you why are you is this
just like a yearly check-in or what and
I'm like well no I was tasked to ask you
these and I know they don't make sense
because
in light of the Hobbes decision you know
you you're you're probably happy right
and so all of that combined and then I
had a January 6th one where the FBI was
trying to get me to serve uh Federal
grand jury subpoena when I had a no
indisha of evidence to do so and
um
and then on top of that during that lead
that I got that I also had a facial
recognition match they claimed it was a
facial recognition match
they used a driver's license photo from
about 25 years prior to say here's your
facial recognition match and
that's inappropriate law enforcement
activity and even when I was pushing
back on that I still had a guy saying
you have a match and I was like but I
don't because here's the current
driver's license photo and the guy looks
way different he has he's bald he's you
know 150 pounds heavier than the match
and it's like this is this is wrong
there's no due process here
um and then that one was also based off
of an anonymous tip which holds very
little weight
um navarrette versus California is the
Supreme Court law that gets into
anonymous tips in law enforcement
um
I'm trying to think what else I can talk
about because I've done there's been a
number of things and but you said
padding the stats you also mentioned
that is that exactly what you're blowing
the whistle on yeah that was that and
then the concern for Public Safety where
they were going to be using the SWAT for
a guy who said I'll cooperate um so I
thought put him at risk and then and
then the ensuing time since my
suspension I think we're both kind of
become uh whistleblowers at least in the
public sphere reasonably for Garrett
um about how the law you're citing is
not being respected or adhered to by the
FBI as far as we're we're experiencing
tremendous retaliation and the FBI has
found a hack to circumvent that law and
they use the security clearance
suspension process to do that and Steve
you were you're you were going after
child exploitation human trafficking
child uh sexual abuse they take you off
of that to put you on we got to make
sure these people like get in deep deep
trouble for January 6. that was what you
were actually doing like real work real
change and they take you off to do yeah
and then to elaborate in that just to
quickly uh
I was on those cases I I was told that
hey just make yourself available for
these terrorist cases because there's
really not a lot of work to do
um so for actually I'm I was told to
commit essentially time card fraud which
is a felony and on my time card I was
saying I am a domestic terrorist agent
um and I wasn't really doing anything
because those cases had been already
worked they were sitting in DC waiting
for them to tell us what to do in the
meantime I kept working my child born
cases to the point where I got an award
about six weeks before I was suspended
for my work on child support cases which
I wasn't supposed to be doing wow guys
you guys both the question all we keep
hearing from the left is with Biden all
these it's just like every day it's the
same BS that the biggest threat to this
nation is white supremacy and domestic
terrorism age I'm pretty sure I know the
answer do you guys believe in that and
if you had to pick one that obviously is
not that what would it be the biggest
threat to us as Americans
so I was a domestic terrorism agent that
was yeah that was what I was assigned to
and uh I'm not saying it isn't a threat
and that there are threats in that realm
but uh white supremacy I I didn't see it
um domestic terrorism as the biggest
threat I didn't see it it's just the
boogeyman for today and
um I put it like this go back through
the FBI's history
1920 we had the Palmer Raids which the
FBI rounded up a bunch of Communists and
deported a bunch of them
without due process there was like one
in 100 who got charged with anything
fast forward to the 30s the FBI rounds
up Japanese in this country and puts
them in internment camps fast forward a
little bit more FBI tries to get Martin
Luther King Jr to commit suicide fast
forward a little bit more it's uh
Weather Underground in the 80s fast
forward to the 90s it's uh domestic
terrorism like Waco and Ruby Ridge and
all that 2000 Patriot Act which by the
way would be Hoover's wet dream
um yeah because because he was big on he
was big on intelligence too Patriot Act
opened the floodgates for the FBI to
gather intelligence on everyone and
patreon supposedly was for
uh um International threats it has been
not so now we fast forward after the
Muslim extremist threat is over
now it's turned inward domestically and
so it's just the current Boogeyman his
speech that he gave at that college is
is absolutely ridiculous so if you had
to pick and I want to ask you to see
what what would you say is it still just
actual outside terrorism that's the like
the number one threat to the American
public I think the number one threat to
the American public is a government
weaponized against its people I that's I
was going to say that myself there's an
article here that was written why the
FBI and Democrats are attacking
whistleblowers by Alex gutentag and
Michael Schellenberg I don't know if you
guys have read this or not so humans
humans mentioned the chs's you know the
whole uh uh uh what do you call them the
the confidential humor sources right so
in this article it says core documents
indicate that there were at least eight
FBI informants known as chs's for
confidential human informants into proud
boys which was one of the groups that
organized DeGeneres 6 protests there's
evidence that FBI also had CHS and Oath
Keepers Another January 6th the activist
group and former FBI supervisor
intelligence analyst Georgia told a
subcommittee that the Boston office
asked for video footage from the six
protests the Washington field office
said they could not give access
to the 11 000 hours of video footage
available because there may be UCS
undercover officers or chs's which will
be just talked with confidential human
sources on those videos whose identity
we need to protect and it wasn't just
the FBI who had undercovered informants
and agents in the crowd they were
undercover agents and informants from
other law enforcement enforcement
agencies including the Washington DC
Metro Police who were acting like Trump
support Trump supporters indeed there
may have been hundreds of undercover
government agents and informants both
local and Federal in the crowd on
January 6. some even said there were 100
to 200 Secret Service agents alone at
the Capitol Hill before and during the
breach of the police barriers one Court
filing alleges that there were at least
20 FBI assets at the Capitol so when you
see stuff like this you know and you're
one that's on the other side and we
watched you know the last 10 years
um eight years fifteen six sixteen so
what eight years since seven years since
16 Russia collusion Trump oh man why did
you do you know so even the average
person that's kind of sitting there
saying oh my god the guy I've voted for
is doing this you got to be kidding me
right Democrats obviously ran with it
you know all these guys oh we have a
hundred percent evidence of what
happened here and like uh that wasn't
right oh you guys just a Durham report
ah it's not a big deal let's just move
on you know you know the dossier was
paid for Hillary Clinton let's just move
on to the next stop so and then so Obama
was what Obama knew all along while they
were investigating Trump yeah but you
know what everybody knows because he's
the president and the Mar-A-Lago let's
go do this yeah because he has these
documents so you know January 6 look
what he did it's terrible
the more and more and more they try to
spin this
and and then it comes out two three
years later as being bad The credibility
keeps taking a hit to the point where
now they're talking about you know
people are running for president talking
about getting rid of the FBI because
it's messing up uh the nation and
dividing us right how much of what Al
Alex and Michael wrote were you guys
aware of where they are saying hey we
want you guys to go there undercover and
join these organizations to kind of work
like you know what uh our friend did
with the mob back in the days in the 80s
what's his name that the movie came out
Donnie Brasco yeah Joe pastone you know
like he was six years he was undercover
Five Years on ten months how much of
that was happening with January 6 and
the Trump organization
I think a tremendous amount of that was
going on and let's just we can remove
the January 6 aspect to it let's take
another case that's a little smaller
scale let's take the Gretchen Whitmer uh
Wolverine Watchman case which I actually
had involvement in the governor of
Michigan you're saying this where the
the Homegrown terrorists were gonna
kidnap kidnap that story yeah yeah okay
yeah and so
the the demand for domestic terrorism in
this country is from the political Elite
in this in the uh the people standing at
the lectern it vastly outstrips the
supply that actually exists and the
nature of the FBI that has now evolved
from law enforcement to domestic
intelligence collection uh our friend
Kyle Serafin puts us really well
criminal investigations are linear
beginning crime happens middle
investigate and there's a conviction
intelligence operations are circular you
open an investigation up to get more
intelligence what does that get you more
intelligence was they get you the
ability to spin out other investigations
that are more intelligence so because
there's a demand for domestic terrorism
and then there's these intelligence
operations that go on you infiltrate
these groups that are deemed to be
problematic or they could be a threat
they could be a domestic terror group so
you take this this group of guys in in
Michigan who is not predisposed to doing
this but you infiltrate it with
Undercovers and informants and the thing
about informants are they know they're
informant nobody else does they don't
know if if Garrett and I have both
infiltrated the Wolverine Watchmen as
informants we wouldn't know that
so then you get a situation where
they're in the room and I'm like trying
to be report back to my guy so I can get
paid hey you know it would be a good
idea we should we should maybe come up
with a plot here to do something and
then he's got to one-up me because he
wants to report back to his Handler and
he get paid and that's how the thing can
snowball out of control and that's why
you see these situations like on January
6th or back to Whitmer where these guys
were not predisposed to engaging in
something that was going to be violent
or anything that could be construed as
terrorism and in fact at one point in
that case the group was breaking down
and the Agents were telling their
informants hold it together which is not
in keeping with the tradition of law
enforcement if there's a if there's a
plot to rob a bank and on the way one
guy's like nah that's not you don't
arrest him for robbing the bank
now on January 6th there I I'm very
confident that there was infiltration
from informants and Undercovers on not
just the FBI who gets painted with the
brush of being federal law enforcements
everything the Department of Homeland
Security has 10x the budget of the FBI
and has a Nexus 2 terrorism and National
Security so see we saw that guy uh Ray
Epps which he was all over the internet
all we kept seeing is this guy who
looked like a carbon cutout of an of a
freaking agent Mega hat Grace uh khakis
he was verbally on camera saying we need
to go we need to attack the capital if
that's not inciting violence apparently
they interviewed him and then they let
him go everybody else that was just on
the bus showing up was arrested the FBI
went after them do you guys have any
idea who that guy is what agency he
might have worked for because it looks
it looks pretty apparent to People Like
Us who that type of guy is did you track
on his responses to the questions I I
saw I saw I did see him message changing
his uh his nephew or something I forgot
what was he saying he's just like I
started I started so how does the FBI
not go after that guy yet they're going
after people that barely did they were
just there you know what I mean yeah so
I think it's clear to anybody paying
attention yeah the only answer is that
he's working with the government to some
degree because no I don't I don't have
any
personal knowledge of that but it
doesn't take a suspended FBI agent to
see that information and be like oh yeah
he's he's got to be involved somehow
because
and there's video of him like pushing
Gates and saying go go and the night
before saying we're storming the capital
and the taxis nephew but he's not
charged instead he gets a puff piece on
60 Minutes a few weeks back
especially when we know the media is
controlled by the government and the
left and we're we're finding out in the
Twitter files and things that continue
to come out that the media that the CIA
has involvement with our own media so it
it seems very clear to anybody who's
been paying just even a small amount of
attention that he's got to be his
answers yeah were very lawyerly he he
always says I didn't work for the FBI
the question should be have you ever
worked for the government true well and
this so as agents when we have a CHS
when we talk to them we have to and I
think this actually came out of the
church committee hearings in the 70s
because back then because some of the
informants back then testified publicly
and the the way they responded was I was
working for the FBI I was working with
the FBI we have to explicitly tell chs's
now you can't claim that you work for or
with the FBI like it's not a job we have
to tell them that so when when someone
answers I've not worked for the FBI
he's remembering what he was told by his
handlers potentially yeah for you guys
uh take off your FBI hats for a second
and just be regular good old Americans
all right we're talking about January 6
for a second how do you process what
actually happened that day and what do
you think the FBI did right and what do
you think they definitely did wrong what
do you think
I think that uh it was not this wasn't a
perfect puzzle piece that went all
together I think that President Trump's
ascendancy brought a lot of people who
were novice and new to the political
process he got a lot of people very
excited voting for the first time
engaged in politics couple that with the
2020 shutdowns where essentially
politics became sports and entertainment
for a lot of people and I think that
there was genuine belief on a lot by a
lot of people that they were going there
to exercise their first amendment and
that they had the opportunity to pause
this transfer of power this
certification of the election because
they just want to quote unquote stop the
steal stop the steal they and there was
questions that were never really
answered after the election there was
definitely some some questionable things
that happened and and nobody ever got a
satisfactory answer to that and I can
understand them being upset I think that
there were people there that did for the
for that purpose I think that there were
some groups there like the uh like the
proud boys who after 2020 watching
Cities Burn said I think antifa needs to
get a butt kicking and they went there
prepared to get in a fight with antifa
because they were just pent up rage at
that point and that has now been
weaponized against some of these
prosecutions that they were there for
violent purposes and then I think there
was also a government infiltration
aspect to it because they had these
groups infiltrated they had Undercovers
there and might not necessarily have
been saying hey we're gonna plan to
start an incident that's going to allow
us to investigate thousands of Americans
and initiate a seditious conspiracy
charge against the candidate for
presidency I don't think there was a
master plot in the back filled
smoke-filled room with a guy with a cat
um but yeah you're thinking of Dr Evil
right now
so and then to the FBI is uh involvement
in this what do you think they did right
and what did they do wrong
oh yeah that's it hard to get one right
and it's kind of hard the FBI didn't do
anything right
I don't I don't think that's true
um because it's hard for me to remove
that FBI agent hat I know because of how
because I have now I have knowledge you
know and I have lots of video that I
watch when we're getting those leads and
so there there were people that day who
absolutely should have been arrested
there were people that day who were
fighting with cops or pushing through or
whatever but then there were people who
walk into the Capitol and there's no
fracas going on yeah and I I know of one
case that I don't know where the guy
came from or whatever and I think he's
even like a marine veteran he walks in
and you see on video he talks with a
capital police officer and according to
him the capital police officer told him
he had to leave and so he left yeah and
he got charged that was the video I
believe Tucker played yeah and he got
charged why is that guy so you're saying
it's important to delineate between who
was actually doing criminal activity
fighting with cops really doing certain
stuff versus right a guy who just kind
of was there raising through the capital
right or we've seen the pictures of the
people basically in line like they're at
the capitol for a tour yeah and and sure
misdemeanor trespass maybe at the most
for a lot of those people but is the FBI
really in the doj really going to doing
be doing a full court press on all those
people well they are but why because
they're actually altering the way
they're perceiving and and there were
conversations that I I was told about
that happened where they said stop the
steel is going to be a predicated uh
domestic terrorism ideology and oh let's
put a pin in this case right now let's
go back through the code book and see if
we can find anything else to charge him
with that's find me a man I'll find in
the crime and now the uh the whole if
you went to the four walls of the
capital uh you were you were going to
get this four pack of charges one of
which is an Enron case I mean crime like
ridiculous but now they say they're
going to uh charge anybody that was on
the lawn on the outside because the lawn
is going to be in retroactively made a
restricted area gotcha well to use an
analogy you brought up uh the the
coveted riots George Floyd protests
everything like that it'd be like going
to one of the protests and just holding
up a sign you know free speech whatever
it is
um hands up don't shoot whatever it is
versus is actually being one of the
arsonist blowing up buildings right
correct there's a big difference there
yeah correct one is legal and within
your right and one is highly illegal
right is that essentially what you're
trying to delineate between yeah January
6. if you're walking through the capitol
peacefully all right cool you're Road
testing versus someone who's actively
has weapons on them fighting with cops
what have you is that essentially your
point it is and especially for the
people who were there but didn't go in
the capital or just in the area what are
they getting investigated for so those
people are being investigated yes and
that's what you're blowing the whistle
that's essentially patting the stats for
domestic terrorists domestic extremists
it is yeah and and your point about
2020. I think is is a is a point in
example of how the FBI got January 6
wrong because none of what we have seen
with January 6 happened in 2020 and I
know the naysayers would say yeah well
uh because those protests didn't happen
in the seat of power of this nation
I say as a as a law enforcement officer
that doesn't matter because there were
people traveling to those protests in
Portland and Minneapolis or wherever so
when you travel when you're not from
there that's an interstate crime if you
engage in criminal activity that makes
it a federal crime but we didn't have
these massive you know uh task force set
up to try to get all the people who were
burning down police stations but for
January 6 it's go arrest every single
person who was even on a lawn you know
my family was on the lawn uh the night
of the day after or the night of the
hearing and we kind of joked about it
and it's like oh our is the FBI going to
be coming for them just because we were
here you know like and I think that's a
general sentiment that a lot of
Americans have right now like the FBI is
the actual Boogeyman not this trumped-up
idea of domestic and to go deeper on
those riots for example even when you
know
um when George Floyd was killed the
whole narrative was like listen not all
cops are bad these are a few bad apples
the whole Bad Apple thing hey and all
these these teachers aren't
indoctrinating kids is a few bad apples
all these athletes aren't beating their
wives there's a few bad apples this
whole concept of being a bad apple but
sometimes
the apple is actually rotten to the Core
so you hear the the concepts that the
FBI is being uh the politization of the
FBI or the weaponization of the FBI so
regarding the FBI are there just a few
bad apples and Bad actors or is the FBI
rotten to the core at this point and
what would you say uh I'm back to the
disconnect between the rank and file and
the management class and the fact that
those guys have to go back and forth to
DC all the time and their priorities are
within self for their self-promotion and
not for the the good of the American
people they're not about the casework I
think there are people that do genuinely
good work in the FBI I think that that
work can be done by other people just as
effectively so if you ask me you made me
King for a Day the FBI wouldn't exist
anymore and and I'm not I'm not a defund
the police guy
um I I think that you can Empower local
law enforcement in a way that you make
you deputize locals and make them give
them Federal Authority and there's a
whole thing we can get into with that
um but I think as far as from the
leadership standpoint for that you can't
just take out Christopher Ray and expect
it all to get better now Christopher Ray
needs to go and and uh just quick math
on him nine million dollar salary the
year before he became the FBI director
gave that up to begin the FBI director
for 10 years
so he essentially gave 90 million
dollars up to become the FBI director is
that what the tenure is for 10 years
it's a 10 years I'm wondering why Biden
didn't fire him because Trump hired him
in 17. good question right so you would
think if Trump appointed him yeah yeah
he's he's acceptable and I I think that
he sacrificed 90 million dollars for the
cause and that's why he got in a uh into
an interview he was with an interview
with Brett Bear and he was asked very
directly what about the FBI's negative
uh image and he said well we have a
record number of applicants so it's all
good and guy it's a down economy and
inflation's through the roof and you're
bragging about your number of applicants
for a job where people can make six
figures to do if they were a cop they'd
be getting paid a third of that
so so I'd like to ask you guys a
question so as far as back well I'm
going to go back to where Pat said 2016
from the Hillary obstruction to uh
Crossfire her to all the fake collusions
like every couple months every it's just
FBI messing up messing up messing up
messing up what is it going to take I
know it's the upper echelon of the
managerial but what is it going to take
to change that like what what needs to
happen to make that that like grasp on
it like break up and be more like less
biased because that's all we're seeing
with bias with Peter struck with all
these it's like they're embedded in
there right they are they are embedded I
think at a minimum you have to clear
house the whole all of headquarters
definitely the seventh floor probably
all of headquarters you have to clean it
out and start from scratch but
a lot of the people like Steve talked
about earlier who get attracted to the
managerial positions in the FBI they're
that type of person who likes the DC
life and the notoriety or whatever
there's this talk of the FBI getting a
new headquarters building
they shouldn't get one that part of
their budget should be should be
scrapped until the FBI is fixed if they
ever are allowed to have a new
headquarters it shouldn't be in DC
because it's attracting too many people
who care too much about the politics I
mean look what they did with the Russia
collusion it and no nobody is paying for
it no accountability at all during
report basically said uh Obama Biden the
AG FBI CIA everybody colluded to try to
cheat the real cheating of an election
and zero accountability nobody's gonna
see I was telling Pat before he walked
in there to all the young people out
there that are wanted you know they're
in crime you want to steal you want to
be corrupt you want to don't do it if
you want to get away with it become a
Democrat be a leftist you could do all
that [__] and never go to prison you're
right so that I mean that's a coup
that's a bloodless coup and I know
people oh that's extreme read the Durham
report look at the facts the FBI offered
Christopher Steele a million dollars as
a CHS payment to if he could corroborate
that dossier and he wasn't able to do it
and the FBI still went straight ahead
and opened a full investigation on then
a presidential candidate and then kept
it going on us on a sitting president
that's is if isn't that treason like are
they that's ridiculous the hell would
the hell with the elect that's the
election that was really but then we get
accused of treason exactly for those are
the bad guys yeah that's on pbd how much
of what they're saying as far as like
the seventh floor is reminiscent of the
book The Barbarians the bureaucrats I
mean that's what it is though that's
what I'm asking the market is filled
with bureaucrats and Aristocrats uh so
you go back and you said something about
9 million 10 years 90 million so why did
Trump appoint him 2007 August exactly so
why what what point were you trying to
make about Chris Ray I I think that he
who gives up and by the way just just
for the audience that's watching this if
he can go put uh uh Chris Ray 9 million
he was with the law from King and
Spalding okay he made 9.2 million
dollars working as an attorney for the
law firm King and Spalding and then he
chose to become a FBI director so go
ahead well I think there's obviously a
steam attached to that and he would
probably argue that it was a financial
sacrifice on his part and for his family
because he wanted to serve America but
what he won't tell you is he gets to
live the life of a billionaire now
flying a private jet all over the place
uh for the price of a the lowest
Southwest ticket that one of his
staffers can find for him he gets that
ability so he gets to have the esteem of
being the FBI director but if you just
go to the simple dollars and cents I I
think that that sacrifice on his part
represents conviction when it comes to
seeing the full weaponization of the FBI
come to fruition underneath his tutelage
it's something that well give me the
ring of power and I'll make sure that it
goes for good for what I deem to be good
and and he's a republican he was so he
was uh
he was appointed by a Republican
president he was recommended to Donald
Trump by Chris Christie because he
helped Chris Christie fix the bridge
gate case he's a fixer and in my
conversations with folks who I work to
work with now who work at the Department
of Justice he's not an intellectual
Titan he's just got a really nice you
know nice haircut and and will do you
don't make 9.2 million just with a nice
haircut if that was a case I got like 50
friends I'm telling you they should be
getting paid way more than they're
making right now because they have nicer
haircuts I should be too yeah you
definitely need to be your billionaire
look right there but but going back to
it like you're not going to be a dummy
making 9.2 so I'm really I want to know
about this Chris Ray guy because
you're making 9.2 you drop it you're you
get your job by Trump recommended by
Christy you know and now Christy's
flipped obviously yesterday I saw the
funniest meme that said Chris Christie
should run all the time
so going back to it this guy's not a
dummy no I I mean he's he's obviously an
educated guy but I think if you go back
a few months he's taking that trip to
the world economic Forum now okay and he
wasn't getting that and with his nine
million dollars and what I mean by the
way I'm not I'm I'm a I'm not a world
economic Forum guy not a fan of cloud
Schwab can't stand
estudiici corporate Equity equality
index I'm not a fan of HRC human rights
committee I'm not a fan of open Society
foundation so this is not an endorsement
of that but okay if you are going to be
the director of CIA you're probably
going to go to world economic Forum
you're probably going to go to a lot of
these weird meetings
so what why give up that 9.2 million and
you get the job by Trump like let me let
me kind of put it this way when whenever
a CEO Trump is a CEO whenever CEO is
hiring a c-suite a director of FBI is a
c-suite
I think there's got to be a more
thorough investigation into assigning
that job to somebody rather than that
you like that guy put him in right so to
me you know if the other side also says
hey man so why did you give him the job
you had other options you had other
people to look at so if he did Trump's
not a person that doesn't have
experience doing this he's hired tens of
thousands of people over his career not
low paying jobs million dollar salary
half a million dollar salary
why does a trump with a shrewd
businessman that's a street guy he sat
with the toughest of the toughest done
the biggest of deals why does he pick
him and if he did he must have seen
something in this guy no well he had
that interview I believe about a month
ago where he was asked specifically that
and he said that it was recommended to
him and he wanted somebody that was
going to be acceptable to both
Republicans and Democrats and and that
was really what his thinking on it was I
think he he took recommendations from
people who he trusted on it but I think
then the question is is is is it a trump
issue or is it a Christopher Ray issue I
think Christopher Ray took the posting
because it allows him to have access to
the
seat of power and and maybe financially
fed himself later on but It ultimately
boils down to he is now in a position to
uh impact our country that he wasn't
going to have that opportunity of
working out listen I mean there are a
few jobs that are powerful jobs that's
definitely one of them so if somebody
calls you and says listen we're thinking
about offering you the director of CIA
job you have to consider that that's not
a lightweight job that's a job that
comes with a lot of different uh uh uh
you know director of FBI you know it
comes with a lot of different
responsibilities but also at the same
time you're in the thick of things like
you know what's going on you're one of
the you know 50 most powerful men in
America that's making these types of
decisions so I get why he would
entertain that I think this is the clip
you were talking about if you want to
play this clip about Chris and Trump and
we are all examples of that
I can't think of a martial learning way
to end a hearing I yield back well he's
looking for corruption weaponization Rob
was watching a movie on Netflix
apologies from our behalf okay please
it's all right
we missed the entire thing up with the
movie he was watching about things that
they are doing that are wrong that's not
it there it is again that's like Pat
while he's looking for that how would
Jarrett doing his thing Pat what would
make you as a business guy and you're
making 9 million a year for this what
would make you give up being almost 100
million dollar man to do that oh you you
definitely would do it you definitely do
to be that just the power the
responsibility of a man is to do the
following if you're a true American
number one make your money number two
protect your wife and your kids set
aside money for her and them where
they're taking care of number three take
care of yourself financially number four
give back to the country the country
that give you this incredible life
Public Service comes in many different
ways one is church one is military one
is non-profit one is government you pick
and choose which one you want to do so I
totally understand why he would say yes
to that life is not just about making
the 9.2 every single year this is a
heavy weight job and there's almost a
duty
when you get a call from the top
especially president offering you a job
whether you like it or not
you you have to really take it for
consideration because
it's it's a it's a listen you get a call
from the top saying hey you got orders
you're going to Camp Casey I'm going you
got orders you're going to Afghanistan
you're going You're a coward if you
don't take it right there's an element
of that so there's there's some of it
that's Public Service well do you think
it was any of it was kind of Nefarious
where he's like okay I'm gonna get in
and now got you I don't know the guy I
don't know the guy all I know is look if
Rob if you can figure out if you got
that clip to go back to it if it's still
messing up don't worry about it but
before you even play this clip if you
can do me if you ever go to statista
with the report I just sent you with the
trust American people having the FBI
this is just from 2019 to 2022 okay blue
is Democrats to have the same amount of
trust in FBI as they did in 2019 as they
do today uh dark uh navy blue is overall
is down from 57 to 44. Independents are
down from 48 to 41 that's down seven and
then Republicans are down 46 to 26 down
20. so Democrats obviously love what the
FBI is doing because they're targeting
the guys that they hate the most by the
way there's nothing about this that's a
Fox News Paul this is statista there is
nothing about this that's emotional now
if you go to the other statistic that I
sent you with with this since 1985 I
don't know if you have that one as well
that blue line that blue line means well
that blue that's everybody still wears a
mask on that blue line that blue line
everybody's still wearing a mask yeah I
think I think it's a problem when it's a
hundred percent your political party
over the country yeah like to me I'm
sitting here asking questions about
Christopher he's a republican Trump I'm
like what you just you can't just say oh
it's all everybody's on the other side
as fault no there's some decisions that
respond I text it to you rob you have it
go to your text you don't need to look
for it it won't load oh it won't okay
then don't worry about it then go to the
video go to the video I'll try to send
you a different link with that let's see
what Trump had to say about hiring Chris
Ray you happy with Chris right but just
so you understand I put Chris Ray in
because I wanted to have somebody in
there that everybody including the other
side really wanted it may not have been
the right move let's see time will tell
okay but I wanted to have somebody in
the FBI because I'm an honorable guy I'm
an honest guy I may have made a mistake
but I put somebody in at the other side
everybody agreed to you know who
recommended him to me Chris Christie
okay he recommended him and that's okay
I don't mind that I've taken Chris
Christie's recommendations before uh and
other people wanted Christopher Ray and
people from the other side wanted
Christopher is investigating yeah so I
remember I remember how recent was that
this is not too long ago no this is like
a uh this has got to be a couple months
ago right March of 2023. there you go
yeah this is a couple months ago before
I'm saying that yeah so for me going
back to it saying well Chris read this
Chris rate that I got a follow-up
question for you here uh that has to do
with the public you were kind of going
through with the question
is We the People right with where we're
at at what point do you see like you
know how uh the government is Randy got
the president and then the governors get
to decide how they handle covet if we're
going to shut it down in California not
essentially essential Force like no no
we're opening schools we're opening this
hey here's what we're going to do in
South Dakota but here's what we're doing
in Illinois Michigan shut it down if
it's a New York this is what we're doing
but this is what we're doing in
Tennessee and this is what we're doing
in Texas okay so the states kind of get
a chance to make their decisions for
themselves is the FBI really going to
let officers work cases rather than DC's
HQ controlling it I mean is it time like
for the FBI to roll up into the DHS or
is it time to kind of just you know
disband them and move move on what do
you think they need to be doing and will
they do that will they allow you know
different markets to kind of do their
jobs without saying no we're going to
step over you and here's what we need to
do I don't know that they'll allow it
the FBI has ever since Hoover really
they've grown into this entity that even
within the doj they they basically are
in charge of themselves they always
essentially have been and they will hold
on to that power as as long and as much
as they can and I think part of the
issue with Ray might be he was a doj guy
before his lavish career as an attorney
that's another problem I think with the
FBI and the doj is the FBI directors
continue to come from doj and so now you
have like this um it's basically like
this intercession where the head of the
FBI
was a doj guy I think that's problematic
because that that limits the checks and
balances potentially but overall
at the FBI doing the right thing and
giving up some of that control I don't
see it happening and I don't know if
there's enough well look at what's
happening in Congress right now with
this Source reporting the FBI just
literally does whatever they want so I
don't I don't know if there's an entity
that could even make them break up uh
and limit some of the power and control
that they have and Seed it over to DHS
or somewhere else but that would be my
fear about we're going to massively
perform the FBI because they would be
Clinging On to the power that they have
now as far as being Regional with the
way that cases are investigated they are
done to a certain extent that way now
and do you have a case you have the
office in El Paso they're going to have
a lot more drug trafficking and Border
related activity just geographically
then
Omaha Nebraska so they're able to sort
of
drill down on what they want now what I
would like to see happen is I want to
pair back the domestic intelligence
collection and maybe we could model
something after the way that the UK does
their law enforcement because currently
having a law enforcement slash domestic
intelligence agency that's the stuff of
the Stasi and the KGB that's secret
police stuff if you go to the UK they
have MI5 that's domestic intelligence
and we can debate whether or not how
what the extent of what the powers they
have but they don't have guns they don't
have the enforcement power all they can
do is bring that intelligence over to
Scotland Yard and make recommendations
and and assist them in their law
enforcement and then Scotland Yard can
use their discretion as far as bringing
criminal charges if you did something
like that that might be something that
that could be debated
um as far as the nuts and bolts of
operating the FBI only has 14 000 agents
the majority of the work is not done in
the big cities it's done in the Resident
agencies that like Wichita Kansas and my
Daytona Beach teacher Sioux City Iowa
where I worked those cases are brought
in by these small offices that liaise
with local law enforcement it's
impossible to do the work of federal law
enforcement without assistance from your
local Partners in Daytona we had eight
agents for an area and the encompassed
one million people can't police that
with eight people you have to rely on
your Sheriff's offices your police
departments and there's nothing in the
the the Task Force officer deputization
process that goes on where essentially
you bring guys in the FBI pays their
overtime and deputizes them as U.S
Marshals gives them Federal arrest
Authority in addition to their state
arrest Authority they bring in the local
knowledge and the local cases that say
Hey that would be great could we bring
some fed charges against this
organization or this this occurrence
that happened in my community and that's
what the fbis should be there for to
assist the locals because they know
where The Usual Suspects are the FBI is
just nerds that are sitting in an office
for the most part that's that's a chart
right there by the way so so we just
learned today agents are nerds but very
probably the biggest reveal today so
this is a public trust in the government
from uh 58 to 2022 and if you look at
that from Eisenhower Kennedy say flat a
little bit higher and Eisenhower you
know warned about military industrial
complex Kennedy comes in they definitely
don't like the Kennedys for what they
have going on and then boom he's out
then Johnson comes in he loves power and
control so that goes down Nixon comes in
trust goes down obviously Watergate all
of that Ford comes in flat Carter comes
in down Reagan comes in he increases the
trust in the government during that
eight year Bush comes in goes down
Clinton comes and increases Bush comes
in down Obama comes in Flat Line Trump
comes and he increases it now Biden's in
here and you don't have the 2022 to this
is uh the number I gave you was once
showing how dramatically it's dropped
the last three years uh the other one
that we were looking at which kind of
shows a completely different perspective
so
when you see this you know the closest
uh of institution that I can see as a
case study to the FBI is the mob and in
the mob there's something called omerta
omerta is when you uh you never share
what's going on on the inside you
essentially don't whistleblow in the mop
and if you do XYZ they're going to come
after you and all this stuff right so
there's a threat of never one of the
code of honors of importance is not
coming out of Silence in the face of
questioning by authorities or Outsiders
and non-cooperation with authorities the
government or outside especially during
criminal investigations and willfully
ignoring and generally avoiding
interference with it I mean this sounds
like Hillary Clinton when she was being
held you know when she would not answer
anything yeah no no I play no no no no
no no no no right and when comey's going
through all this stuff 33 000 emails
what's the big deal yeah what's the
what's the big deal you delete emails
all the time what is the difference
between she broke her computer maybe she
was pissed off at Bill what does that
have to do with you anyways they were
talking about yoga pants right obviously
that's what the emails were all about
she wiped it with a rag yeah yeah
sweetheart right yeah but but here's the
part is there an omerto model in the FBI
where hey guys whatever we're doing
there's one thing you can ever do as an
FBI agent you can never whistle blow and
then behind closed doors you're being
trashed to say you guys can never trust
them because they whistle if you talk to
them just as soon as they're recording
the conversation just assume they're
going to say this is there that kind of
a Vibe and and energy in the FBI as well
or no
tell them about the training the new
training ah yes there is that Vibe for
sure and you got to tell them about your
ASAC and what he said to you but every
year every federal employee has to have
it's mandatory by government uh
whistleblower training every single year
and Insider threat training every single
year
and my whole time in in the FBI they
were always separate this year we found
out because thankfully there are still
some good people in the FBI uh that that
training was merged into one so the FBI
didn't even they didn't even say you
know whistleblowing is good and you can
do it like they used to they used to say
yeah it's protected uh now they combine
those trainings overtly saying
whistleblowers are Insider threats I
mean that was the takeaway from the
people we know in the agency who took
that training that slide deck was
released to the public so we can go see
it it's online and it's like okay so the
FBI is not even trying to hide the fact
that they will retaliate against you and
I think that's government-wide look
what's happening with the IRS
whistleblower in his Squad right now but
the FBI has a culture they have had a
culture since Hoover's era of FBI first
no matter what and if you go against the
FBI I can see them we're coming for you
well I applaud you guys for
speaking truth to power right you're
shining light on Justice there's a lot
of people that probably do not want you
talking whatsoever who would you say is
at the top of that list what names what
people what institutions are like
Garrett friend get these guys silence
these guys muzzle them right now who's
at the top of that list I think the DNC
as a whole we we were you know in-person
recipients of that uh at that hearing
the things they were saying the way they
were twisting things and lying about us
and about our whistleblower status and
comparing us to people who committed
Espionage and whatever else and then uh
I think the mainstream media as well
because they're lackeys of the political
Elite and the political Elite are
typically on the left and so my
deposition that I went to in February
really stands out for me because I was
led to believe just like I was with my
transfer I was led to believe in good
and I I accepted both in good faith that
everything was kosher so I go to my
deposition a couple weeks later I get a
call from my attorney and he says hey
buddy I got I got some bad news for you
I got a call from CNN and they have your
name and they have some information
about your deposition I was told don't
talk about this deposition unless it's
with a privileged party and so I left
that deposition thinking like I you know
hopefully they will investigate this and
I told them there to the Democrat
attorneys as well who sat in on the
deposition because that's what I agreed
to do
because it's not a partisan issue or it
should not be a partisan issue but we're
seeing that it clearly is it's a right
or wrong issue it's like bro you have a
soul you you want to just be a good
person you're a Christian and it's like
we talk about this many podcasts evil
right now I don't care what anybody
thinks out there evil is winning so hard
and it's embedded in our government the
governments of the world and I feel like
it's we need people like you but their
their power is so freaking strong
they've all they've all sold their souls
to the devil and the price is not cheap
bro I gotta hold up that bargain who
else would you put on the list you get
the DNC you get the mainstream media
obviously the FBI um okay yeah at the
FBI as a whole the ray certain
bureaucrats every other agent SES level
yeah at least or HQ as a whole most
likely okay who would you say yeah I
would I would agree that the executive
levels and also at the Department of
Justice too
um and uh
it even goes down to the the management
structure uh even the ASAC level uh so
assistant special agents in charge that
are still on the GS scale because they
are climbers don't ruin my gig for me so
um I'll name check Colt markovsky and
Sean Ryan as the asacs who sat in the
office for me and when Colt marcott when
I said to him that I took an oath to
protect the Constitution and he
responded back to me you have a duty to
the FBI
that was just a watershed moment for me
I when I took my oath I tore that oath
in front of God and my family and people
who sat around me who I thought were my
friends how uncomfortable is it to
actually name names at this point I I
mean I I wouldn't uh I wouldn't pee on
him if he was on fire
wow here's my question to both of you
since you guys you know were in the FBI
uh do you think because you guys have
come out you're doing this are they
monitoring you guys are they do you
think is there a possibility because you
guys would know of anybody are they
doing what they actually do for a living
yes are they tapping you guys compound
they monitor are they making sure you
guys don't go I mean I don't know the
depths of how how much I'll be pretty
sure you guys have information but you
think they're watching you guys I I
don't know for sure but the day I got
suspended I had a very odd thing
happened with my phone while I was
talking to an attorney and it basically
cut out and then I couldn't get back in
touch with him and I was getting an
automated message and and once I did get
back in touch with him and this guy this
attorney he's a retired FBI agent as
also and I said hey uh I explained to
him what happened and he goes oh yeah
they probably tapped the phone who do
you think's watching this right now uh
headquarters security division
definitely is I know that for a fact I
did an interview with him and they were
very tongue-cheek about oh we were big
fans of that podcast you did I was like
I'm glad you gave did you give him a
like okay um yeah guys quick reminder uh
like subscribe to Peabody podcast leave
a five-star review yeah yeah going back
to what you were saying when I asked the
question about uh the omerta the code
and they trained you it's FBI Above This
you said you know you got to tell your
story what was the one story you you
wanted to share that was the the he said
my my duty was to the FBI and not not to
the Constitution do you have the clip
about you know uh where I believe
believe it's um I want to say which one
is it where it says they will destroy
you they will crush you and your family
I think you have the clip if you can
play this clip uh uh uh on yeah it's
that one right there
uh this is a
Karen is this this is you talking in
this one yeah that's you just played a
whole clip I want the whole thing we
have a 20 second one we'll play this one
all of the hardships you've gone through
if one of your really good friends your
former colleagues came to you and said I
have this thing that is being covered up
and I think the American people know to
need to know about it
what advice would you give them
I'll tell them first to pray about it
long and hard
and I would tell them I could take it to
Congress for them
or I could put them in touch with
Congress
but I would advise them not to do it so
you would legitimately try to protect
one of your colleagues from doing what
you have done absolutely
and how do you think that solves being
able to shine light on corruption
weaponization any kind of Mis misconduct
that exists with the American people it
doesn't solve it but the FBI will crush
you this government will crush you
and your family
if you try to expose the truth about
things that they are doing that are
wrong and we are all examples of that I
mean that's pretty powerful I can't
think of a more sobering way to end a
hearing I feel back
so so you would tell them not to so now
if you go back
a year ago and you're having that
conversation with your wife whatever the
timeline is when you when you you
wouldn't have done what you've done
already
uh I'm not saying
if I had a crystal ball I don't know
because how do you sleep at night then
and you know I have four little girl
girls now back then we had three and I
had a conversation with my ASAC at one
point and he was trying to walk me off
the ledge a little bit and I think he
was
he was he was acting like me doing the
wrong thing so just toeing the line
um was caring for my family I think that
that's cowardice and in the Book of
Revelation it tells us that cowards will
be judged uh when when they sit before
the Lord and
how could I then as a man raise my
daughters to be women of integrity and
to do the right thing even when it's
hard if I wasn't willing to do it so I'm
not saying I wouldn't have done it but
uh you know the congressman asked me if
one of my really good friends came to me
with that information Not only would I
do what I answered for a friend I would
do it for somebody that I don't know in
the FBI if if they were were too
unwilling or too afraid to do it but
they knew that they had something that
needed to be brought forward
um
I made that I made my oath many times
twice in the Army once when I
re-enlisted
um as a police officer as an FBI agent I
meant it and I was willing to stand in
the breach I'm in the breach now so
bring it to me that I'm that's fine I'm
I'm okay with that and we will get it to
Congress or whistleblower attorneys or
wherever it needs to go because the
American people need to know this stuff
yeah there's no question about it that
we need to know this stuff but you know
it ruins lives meaning people like you
it ruins your life and you know Sylvia
Garcia I think was a congresswoman from
California was trying to say you're not
a whistleblower you're not a
whistleblower you're not a whistleblower
I think Debbie Wasserman who comes
across as a total sweetheart from
Florida very good hair you know she was
talking about how this whole thing is
about the book and you're doing you know
just the book and then another lady
comes out and says you know I cannot
believe what you guys are doing this is
defunding the police on steroids uh she
was the one from U.S Virgin Islands uh
uh
yeah when she said that so you you see
this stuff obviously this is the part of
discrediting right defund which was
phase one we're suspending you with pay
right if they're suspending you you're
not getting paid no no and then 7 500
which by the way strategically it's the
dumbest thing to do if you want somebody
to go away and not typically what would
happen in businesses here's a severance
package sign this definition Nation hold
harmless and move on they do the
opposite so these guys would be terrible
in business they're dummies if they're
not doing this the way to do this listen
we're going to give you one year this
good luck to you we're sorry it didn't
work out we'll see nothing but the best
but no they cornered you well you have
to do this and come out and talk about
it so also you know running an
organization is not a
wise thing that they're doing the other
thing I want to play if you can play
James Comey here he was being
interviewed this week and the questions
being asked and by the way this is a guy
that loved being interviewed a lot when
this book came out he was everywhere
right Comey Comey Comey and then all of
a sudden he's disappeared a little bit
you know and
but uh this was a interview that was
done what is this like a few days ago a
couple days ago I don't know what the
exact date on this is it's not too too
uh uh this could have been a couple days
ago if you just play it see what he says
here really honest honest loving guy too
yeah so people in law enforcement which
matters so as for the Durham report 300
Pages four years investigating the
investigators one of the things that did
come out of it was that procedures
regular FBI procedures were ignored that
steps were missed along the way in this
investigation in fact director Ray said
when the report came out yeah we
acknowledged that a couple of years ago
and we've changed all that those changes
are already in place do you acknowledge
perhaps that some mistakes were made
along the way oh definitely and they
were found four years ago by the
Inspector General so there's nothing new
in this new document what were some of
those mistakes from your point of view
oh that the FBI didn't communicate
clearly the status of certain sources
they didn't double check certain
information before putting it in a court
application for for a foreign
intelligence wiretap and a bunch of
others and so do you believe now as
these some of these politicians call for
defunding of the FBI that that has been
corrected and then now the procedures
are in place to avoid those kind of
mistakes in the future I think so but in
complex investigations there's always
going to be mistakes it doesn't mean the
FBI is incompetent honest and
independent so director
honest incompetent and independent this
is your former boss how do you feel
about what your former boss is saying
here he's doing the same thing that uh
that the FBI did after the initial
release of the Durham report is that
moveon.org move where this is old news
this is already addressed four years ago
we can't tell you how we did it but but
we did it and again back to his college
of cardinals mindset of on beyond all
ethical reproach or questioning in
anything that there's no personal
accountability there he never says yeah
I messed up he never takes uh any sort
of responsibility for something like
like I'm going to direct agents to go
and talk to Mike Flynn because I hope
that he lacks Candor and we can charge
him with a process crime and I'm going
to brag about it openly isn't that the
player's code you know like guys you
know uh when you're a player and you
have a lot of girlfriends and you're
coming up you know the code is you can
never say you did anything wrong okay
you didn't do this so if James Comey was
a guy that he shows a lot of signs of a
player you know Playboy type of a guy
yeah so he I feel like he listens to a
lot of r b and Hip-Hop he just kind of
seems like that kind of a guy but going
back to it so for him yeah it's not a
big deal so you know it's it's not not a
big deal we've addressed that we've
gotten better it's cool is it is it the
mindset of never ever admit and just
kind of be casual and cool about it and
move on
or is it more a you know cultural thing
of the FBI or is it just him that's
doing this
I think it's the culture of the FBI and
he just embodied it I mean you just you
the reputation for the FBI is everything
to it protect The Shield at all cost
when uh when I was accused of making
this recording of my meeting with my
asacs which I did I was asked about it
in in my interview my compelled
interview which I was not allowed to
have an attorney actually assist me with
just sit there and watch they tried to
get me to lack Candor so they could
charge me and do a search warrant and
arrest me
um I had said yes I created that the
natural follow-up for anybody and these
are FBI agents who are who are asking
these questions is can we get a copy of
that because I was making some rather
huge uh Revelations to them that I was
being possibly compelled to do something
that I felt was a civil rights violation
they never asked for a copy which means
they have a copy as I suspected my asex
recorded the conversation as well and
they were not worried about what they
those guys told me they were just
worried about the exposure
reputation is everything
but by the way can you look at the uh
Yelp to see what their online reviews
are for FBI like how many positive
reviews
that's got to be a joke I was actually
just joking can you read the reviews go
to the bottom tell me this is a joke
this has to be a joke right my family
and I were given a tour de oh it's a
tour thing experience okay go down is it
actually FBI some of the FBI needs to go
race should be the first I had no clue
there by the way if you have bad
experience with the FBI go writer Yelp
reviews
there's no chance go little Lord this is
actually comical now I couldn't even
believe it five stars so I have a
confession my dream job even now is to
work for the Affairs of Fielding it
seems so exciting fun and interesting
saving the world and fighting crime this
is what 2016 with a lot has changed
since then miss Maggie C so go a little
Lord Jerry Lee okay keep going keep
going keep going uh uh so is this one
walking past the back and building I
turned to my husband and said I bet this
is the FBI headquarters I feel like I'm
an episode of The X-Files lo and behold
lo and behold when we reached the front
it was I wish we could have gone inside
but it looked like a closed not sure if
it was a secret thing it was over there
perhaps it was even open like Wally
World from National Lampoon I'd love to
see what Trump left as a review of the
FBI this place is corrupt stupid I would
never come here again
let's do the Durham report before you
know I got a couple other final
questions here before we wrap up so the
the Durham report one of you guys let me
read this one this is an article from um
uh May 16th page four so whistleblower
detail distorted and twisted FBI
weaponization claims right at the top uh
FBI special agent Garrett Boyle
whistleblower revealed the retaliation
he faced after testifying to Congress I
won't hold my breath there uh he stated
I won't hold my bread there because I'm
sure they are going to ramp up the
pressure to try to get rid of me even
more now uh oh Boyle described a
two-tiered system within the FBI
starting at the headquarters level
within which we have talked about that
as well
but it follows up with the story where
is this one here whistleblower is that
the video that says FBI whistleblower
Steve friend explains how the FBI
evolved into an intelligence agency
after 9 11 we talked about that as well
the the Durham report when it came out
it was just kind of like hey yeah cool
moved on nobody really did anything with
it
how much was in there for someone who
actually wants to do investigative
journalism to go deeper to this to hold
some people accountable because there's
a part of America that thinks you know
there are people in jail today that sold
weed 20 years ago that they're still
doing time there's people in jail today
that did a crime much smaller than what
some of these folks are doing at the top
with their different families Biden's
you know Clinton's you hear these types
of stories like how are these guys
getting away with it there was a moment
where it's like is someone going to be
held accountable so when you guys being
a former FBI agents when you read the
Durham report did you go and say to
other agents inside and say listen guys
did you guys read this report what do
you think about this did you see what
was said and then if you did what was
the reaction from your peers was it like
no it's not a big deal what are you
talking about we can't even bring that
up yes did you bring it up too if you
did what was the reaction of your peers
so I was out of the FBI already after
the Durham report came out but as that
investigation was going on Chris James
Comey mentioned how or Chris Ray I
forget one of the clips we watched where
um they implemented years ago fixes for
these things
okay well if if people of integrity and
character were running the
investigations those procedures would
have never had to be fixed anyways
because they wouldn't have been broken
for one but in my circles while I was in
the FBI everybody had the opinion that
the Russian hoax was exactly that a hoax
we knew it already before the Durham
report came out and now that that report
is out I think it's very damning of the
FBI but like you said it's it's just you
know washed over in the media nobody
really cares nobody's paying attention
unless they're digging on their own and
I think that's also problematic about
the doj and the FBI as a whole James
Comey himself refused to be interviewed
during the Durham investigation why why
you were the director of the FBI at the
time but you're not going to interview
for that and then he acts like oh I'm
not no not a big deal we already knew
all this it's that hubris that's
especially at the top but that hubris
people of that character are attracted
to the FBI for whatever reason and it
has infected the agency
yeah
I didn't I mean I was already gone when
the Durham report came out and I
unfortunately my my FBI contacts are
Garrett and the other whistleblowers at
this point the guys I spent the majority
of my conversations with and so we have
our opinions on it but I do know from
from experience that a lot of agents are
just
that's above my pay grade
um I'm not even aware of it helpless
yeah well I mean and even when we were
in the hearing uh we we had it from
multiple people say people didn't even
know you were testifying in front of
Congress that day in the office they're
like I don't know what you're talking
about well for it will fully will fill
ignorance what
we see that at the top too so last week
um Jill Murphy another assistant
director was testifying before I forget
which committee yeah and she straight up
says Eli crane I forget where he's from
but his his questioning of her is is
particularly
um poignant I think and there were some
other ones who asked her some questions
she's never read the Twitter files she's
never read the Durham report uh she's
not giving answers based on the her own
program that she's in charge of she's
not able to provide answers and she's in
charge of it and it's like of
counterintelligence I believe is what
she's a ADN and it's like that also that
willful ignorance or maybe it's even
coerced ignorance to not pay attention
to the things that are going on in this
nation when I got hired by the FBI I
thought it was going to be a national
effort where you're paying attention to
the things happening you're you're doing
your best to do what's right no matter
what but it's simply not the case
because people are
they're they're too comfortable I think
as a nation we've gotten too comfortable
it's that whole cycle of you know hard
times great Hard Men and I think we're
at a in a place where before too long
we're going to be on really hard times
are there are there more whistleblowers
you know other guys who are on the
inside that reach out to you and and are
saying hey man I want to come out but
I'm afraid you know I got a wife and
kids to take care of I got to figure out
a way to have a little bit more savings
before I do this and I don't know what
job I'm going to do after this there's
no way anybody's going to hire me or
those types of conversations being had
right now yes yes yes and and a lot of
people are actually on the inside giving
us information that we're able to come
out with so like yesterday I was able to
come out with the fact that they gave
all FBI employees three paid hours per
week for wellness
now you combine that with the three paid
hours per week for physical fitness for
wellness well mental wellness and
physical and I'm taking a break
things yes you could do yoga and color
and whatever but you can combine that
with three hours for physical fitness
paid lunch
uh FBI agents are supposed to work 50
hours a week most work 40.
um so now you're talking 11 hours out of
40 per week that they're paid to not do
their job
27.5 of the time of an FBI agent to not
investigate why would somebody leave
that shop then correct right okay so
you're saying so you're saying what
you're doing right now is you are the
chief Recruiting office for FBI they
just got 17 000 applications right I'm
going to yeah Hey listen I I heard you
guys are paying well and you don't
expect me to work that's awesome I'm in
right yeah I want that job when it comes
to FBI salary what's a starting mid top
level expectation of what uh and salary
and benefits of what you receive being
an FBI agent so you it's the GS pay
scale you start as a 10-1 but you also
get availability pay which is a 25 bump
in pay so uh talk numbers so it's about
uh 70. yeah as a 10 one yeah that's that
looks about right and then you're at
about 78 Grand right that's where you
start yeah and then after five years you
get promoted to gs13 step one and so you
get the law enforcement availability pay
which is 25 bump this is Agent salary
it's different for the other positions
but
um and then depending on where you live
you get locality pay so one of the
smears they've put out against us is oh
well they're paid hacks from cash Patel
okay go ahead and say that that he paid
us money right before Christmas from his
foundation
um because we had been suspended without
pay already and our whistleblower
activities had already happened the
retaliation had already happened
where I was headed to Virginia I was
going to be making about 132 000 a year
because I would hit my GS 13 uh coming
up here in like another month or so and
um
why would you give that up and the South
the benefits the salary of the job it is
one of those reviews on Yelp oh it looks
like such a cool job yeah it was it was
a great job Steve and I were both SWAT
guys uh which added an extra element of
of you know service and but also like a
more fun aspect instead of sitting in
the the office all the time like instead
of being a nerd like Steve Denver okay
you get the cool guy Factor yeah yeah
yeah and yeah and so you know the new
unit I was heading to I was really
excited about uh what what I was going
to be doing there and
but so yeah for people to say oh they're
just grifters and paid hacks and all
this like not further from the truth and
um but yeah I I've told my wife just
read because all of this you know we
were we're probably getting to a point
where we were uh the callus was forming
over a lot of what has happened and and
now in a very public way it's
um it's all back you know and I'm
talking about it every day which is is
fine I hope that is a part of the
healing process for me but
um this journey has not been easy and if
I could pick Snap My Fingers yeah I
would be making my 130 000 salary and I
would be more or less an anonymous FBI
agent I don't think I really look like
an FBI agent so I blend in well and
um we were comfortable you know but
um now everybody knows that face that
beard that hair cover of GQ out here but
getting outside your comfort zone is is
also a good thing and
I never thought my belief in that would
lead me into something like this but um
as as strange it is as it is to say and
probably to hear I'm grateful uh that
you know the Lord has put this
opportunity in front of me because
I can only go forward and and hopefully
glorify him in the process
that's awesome I will say that you do
have the Adam Sandler Zohan look though
I know that look that's a legit look
yeah I can't get it out of my head right
now that's all I'm thinking about with
the hair doing all this stuff Got A Few
Good Men and we got this off yeah so you
want to just show the picture I mean
there is an element of a little bit of
Zohan stuff going on there it's a good
looking guy okay so uh uh a couple
things here ESG Dei has the FBI been
bullied by the esgdi stuff or not yet
are they sitting there saying hey we
need to make sure the people were hiring
a third of them are from a
underrepresented community whether
they're part of the lgbtq disabled black
you know I was hoping to have Middle
Eastern in there they don't have it but
Native Americans some things like that
is there anything like that happening
within the FBI it's rampant is it really
I know you said about the pride flag
that was in there but what do you mean
full-fledged unpack that for us uh well
intern in my office uh she came in one
day and was a he with blue hair and we
all just had to move on this is somebody
who needed a security clearance to work
in the facility she needed a security
clearance to go from a sheet to a heat
no just to work in the FBI facility
that's why I can't I couldn't be an FBI
agent anymore they suspended my security
clearance for looking at the employee
handbook improperly
and this
being came in and and obviously had some
some mental issues yeah and that was
something that we had to accept and just
move on from the trans woman you're
saying yes and now is that a gun in your
pocket or are you just okay sorry you're
an FPS the academy now has issues where
there are females that are claiming that
they're male but they still want to use
the female standards for the physical
fitness test so they're having to
deal with that speed bump
um how about from the top I mean that
stuff I can see happening because it's a
little you know weird today the market
is a little weird today
how about from the top are you guys
hearing stuff from the top you know the
headquarters Ray people from the top
saying here's what we need to do moving
forward when it comes down to recruiting
guidelines etc etc is that happening
yeah that's that's a full initiative
that we need to do diversity hiring
they've reduced the uh standards for for
some matters of hiring because they want
to increase their pool of minority
applicants and then and and if you just
want to go on a strict gender basis
FBI's majority male it's law enforcement
however they want equal representation
amongst the management class to be male
and female so there's an a
disproportionate amount of female
representation within the leadership
structure because it just isn't there
aren't a lot of females that join the
FBI to begin with so a lot of those
females are elevated very quickly
because they have to fill those slots 50
50 or close to 50 50. how much of this
is trickled down from the stories that
used to come down from J Edgar Hoover
everything you know the story is the
this is the FBI building
cross-dressing high heels we don't talk
about that oh no this is the one that
you can't talk about really it's strict
their voting it's wow you're joking are
you I'm assuming you're joking right
most people don't most people in the FBI
don't know the history of the FBI yeah
it's a government it's a government
agency that you might as well be working
for HUD yeah for most people it is a
government job based on our company what
does that mean you don't know the
history of the FBI I don't know about
Hoover or cointelp
it's it's you guys know more about the
FBI than most FBI employees correct
how's that possible
willful ignorance willful ignorance and
and I think a lot of people that join I
mean look at full disclosure I saw a
Point Break and looking they look like
an awesome job
FBI agent but I also
movies I wanted to be Fox Mulder yeah
wow
so that was the inspiration yeah there's
Jared to go Hoover yeah but I think a
lot of people it's it's a very high
paying job with a lot of esteem attached
to it yeah and there's a great
opportunity to be underworked and
overpaid you know if you're even as an
agent you only have to do one
investigative activity per case every 90
days that's very unfortunate they don't
teach the history of the FBI to you know
it's it's like what we see running
rampant with kids they don't teach
everything about the Constitutional
Declaration of the independence
everything that how government works you
see these men on the street interviews
can you name the three branches of the
government they're like uh I don't know
uh well let me let me ask this question
I'm about to pose this and by the way if
you can put this I'm going to put it on
Twitter as well Rob if you can ask this
question and comment below just anybody
that's watching a pod
what would you like to see the FBI
actually investigate like here's what I
would like to see the FBI investigate
and I'm wondering if any of that even
came up or talked about
uh how much uh how actively are they
investigating uh the list of names from
Epstein how much are they investigating
what happened with Epstein you know
jelaine right now
story came out yesterday she's worried
because she told on a couple of people
that are within the jail she's worried
for her life who knows if she's saying
that or somebody else saying it on her
behalf because this week is the week
where she's going to be meeting the
Saint Peter to decide whether she's
going to Hell or Heaven who knows what's
going to happen to her this week there's
a lot of people in that world that can
predict someone's lifespan it's actually
very good technology they have
um
how much of the investigation into
Epstein is currently happening or when
you guys were in there that was a guy
that they were looking into
I don't have any personal knowledge of
that but I would bet not a whole lot and
you guys probably know this but uh who
is the prosecutor assigned to jolene's
case James comey's daughter uh in in law
enforcement
um I learned quick quickly that there's
not uh crazy there's there's not very
pull this up real quick there's not very
much uh coincidence I'm at a point
especially combined with my faith I
don't believe in coincidence at all I
think it's all it's all happening for a
reason and the FBI and I mean why is
that story not front and center until we
find out about every single person on
that list yeah but we don't ever hear
about it nope yup imagine they took see
they took you off of that type of
investigation like you were
investigating those type of cases right
and they're like no no go after somebody
that was on a bus that wore a mega hat
check this out assistant U.S attorney
Maureen Comey is one of the lead
prosecutors in the case against Miss
Maxwell and had been due to try Epstein
prior to his death in 2019 the daughter
of the former FBI jamescom is the head
of the sdny violent and organized crime
unit and has been with the office since
2014. and by the way isn't the comey's
very good friends with the clintons you
think so no no I'm curious from um I
know he was wearing the the Clinton gear
in 2016 he was taking pictures I don't
know if he's got a relationship oh yeah
and he remember he hit with the with the
who was it who was the Attorney General
Loretta Lynch they they took the charge
from growth negligence to extreme
carelessness and he was just like yeah
whatever bro yeah exactly well dude I
agree with you 100 bro it's like I I
believe in in God I think God you know
chose you to be this person but these
people bro they're so intertwined and
it's so into like that's why my question
earlier I'm like is is it going to
change I think you could take an act of
God because these people are so let's
stay on this though let's stay on this I
actually want to know this a little bit
more uh Rob if he can pull up the shirt
for some people that want to buy this
shirt we want to make sure we give a
shout out to the folks that want to buy
this shirt uh that James Comey was
wearing with the uh
where is it work great marketers and we
have to as capitalists if there's great
shirts we want to help contribute
towards people
this is James comey's Instagram account
in 20 I don't know what the exact
timeline was this is on Instagram uh
when you posted this the exact date uh
is is it 2018 or something like that he
posted this elect more women I think
that was Hillary Clinton August of 2020.
there you go so that's that shirt but
going back to Epstein that is something
people want to know yeah that is
something people want to know people
want to know what's going on there
what's who's behind it so maybe let me
ask the question a different way
so you guys were both FBI agents
if the FBI actually wanted to
investigate and look into what happened
with Epstein as former agents how would
you go about doing that to get the Intel
to find out exactly who was on the list
who did what do we have enough
information do we have enough access to
stuff well we could get that kind of
stuff who would you talk to would you go
to Jolene what would be the procedures
to learn more about what's going on with
the Epstein
well I think from what we do know I mean
there's enough uh Reasonable Suspicion
and probable cause on many people on
that list where you you can
you can open a at a minimum a
preliminary investigation which opens up
some of the FBI's capabilities in
investigating people and I think very
rapidly you would be able to open most
of those into a full investigation and
then the so the FBI is very powerful
they there are some Wizards in the FBI
when it comes to technology or
investigating or just digging into a
case to get as close to the truth as
they can and the the way the Epstein
case has been treated and essentially
brushed under the rug uh should be
alarming to everyone because that should
be as big of a case in the public sphere
as any case that has been in the last 10
years at least because of the type of
people on that list and the type of
bizarre things that have happened along
the way
yeah but give me steps like for what I'm
looking for is the following so for
example I come and I say listen guys
here's what's going on I've had a person
living in this house that I own for the
last three years that paid rent for two
years the last 12 months have not paid
rent I'm trying to ask him to leave
they're saying they don't have to leave
every time I go to the door they don't
even open the door they're doing this
they're doing that the house is trash as
a lawyer what are my next steps on what
to do you would say step number one we
have to apply for this step number two
is we have to send this letter we have
to document this you need to show this
do you have that do we have to take
pictures we have to send this to this
person within and once we get this back
from the city I want to know steps so if
right now
say Chris Ray changes and it's a new guy
comes in okay and you are now
replacement for Chris Ray minus the 9.2
million dollar income that you made this
year you to make that money but you
become the new Chris Ray okay and one of
your top things you want to find out
about is
parents in America have concerns with
pedophilia okay child porn all of that
which by the way I think at one point I
read an article in 2016 FBI was the
biggest distributor of uh you know
whatever access to child porn that they
had there was some article that was
written about that Rob if you want to
look for this but say you have two
things on your list one is child porn
getting to the bottom of who's doing
that okay
and then the other one is Epstein how
would you go about doing it if you are
now Chris Ray today
or I think that they're they have to
avoid the Temptation that they had with
um the Trump investigation where they
they look to headquarters and start a
task force there for people who haven't
investigated crime for a very long time
I would get somebody like Garrett
who has no connection there to do the
work that he's been doing his whole
career from the outside not from the
inside well no from the inside there are
investigators who have experience so and
there's some some great investigators
who know that's all they've done for
decades so I think Staffing is is number
one you can't just say well this guy you
know he's in charge of this division so
he must know what to do that's that's
not how it works it has to be the guy
who you don't know his name because he
spent his entire career arresting bad
guys uh legit actually functioning what
you would have to do is you'd have to
either consider reopening the Epstein
investigation or starting Anew
um if it was my case I'd be probably
arranging for some sort of a proper with
Maxwell where she'd be Queen for a Day
and and reveal what she could to me and
then and and then go off of there and
and start knocking on doors for the the
individual she names because those are
people that are in positions of power
and influence they have a lot to lose
they will want to cooperate fully in
with their own offers it again and
you're just really gonna have to at the
end of it pick your pick your snatch
what would you do similar like that I
mean I guess if it was handed to me and
said all right you're the guy your turn
take over uh first would be a wide
sweeping search of the FBI system on
everything related to Epstein and this
is how I always worked my cases anyways
I would get all the background
information or as much as possible that
already existed in the FBI system and
you know shockingly enough there's a lot
in the various type of systems that the
FBI has and with a case like that I mean
there's so many people involved so I
would start
I'm certain the AFI has some information
then I'm going to start going for each
name each name that's in the case in the
case File no matter how thinly
Associated to it I'm going to dive into
each one of those to find out more what
the FBI already knows and then once I
have as much knowledge as I can about
what has already been investigated I'll
go forward from there and I would
imagine there's enough information to
investigate more people involved the
prison where Epstein committed suicide
and
um uh you know whatever else and uh and
then we have the overseas connections
and the money too that's a big one
follow the money it's always money money
money money money and Epstein is a money
guy I don't
um most of what I know of the Epstein
case came from
um martyrmade podcast he had he has done
a really good long-form series on
Epstein three parts if people are
interested in this case
listen to those
um it's like I said there's no
coincidence in law enforcement the the
Epstein case is a primary example of
that going back historically
um to who he was how he got started his
connections with the clintons uh going
forward to his death
and so there's a it's a big
um there's a lot of meat on the bone
with with that one and so only knowing
okay and I'm sorry good only knowing
only knowing uh what we know in the
public sphere uh I mean that's that's
one layer and so there's a lot more
beneath that and we have access to
enough Intel data contacts relationships
that you could actually get to the
bottom of what happened with Epstein if
I had access to FBI system if you are
the director of FBI and one of your top
three issues was I really want to find
out what the hell happened with Epstein
do you have enough access to find out
exactly what happened and come out with
the intel on that maybe not exactly what
happened but pretty damn close and how
long would it take you to be able to
give that report to the American people
okay it's like that
I don't know yeah I mean it depends on
how many people get brought in and I
mean and then also you're getting with
finances you have to do subpoena bank
records and there's a lapse in time
there I think you could probably do a
pretty good job in a year
pretty good job in a year yeah okay so
within within a year you could get that
Intel to us especially if you had you
know I don't know five five really
staunch case agents and and Intel
analysts or two and that's all you
worked on this is the this is why he
could never be a manager because he
wants to investigate perhaps the biggest
most important case in the country and
says I can do it five people if I had a
manager would want 500 that's true so so
okay let me ask another question so you
guys are on the inside are you seeing
what's going on what do you think the
FBI should be investigating today like
if they were to truly do their job of
what their job is for that we as
taxpayers paid them to do what do you
think are the top three things the FBI
should be investigating today
top three
um I think fentanyl coming across the
border I know we have the DEA but FBI
that's a big part of what the FBI does
because cartels and whatnot I think
that's a big one because it actually
impacts the American people everywhere
um
let's see what else
um election interference actual
investigating it the FBI it's what one
of our purview is but I I'm not really
seeing much actual investigation in it
instead the FBI is interfering with
elections themselves so that's a problem
and then
third probably
probably like gang violence and and that
type of thing because that has only
exploded more since covet really gang
violence has exploded it's gone up okay
so three are you in the same uh uh top
three as well as him uh I mean I would
put child pornography
because it's it's you could assign every
agent to job pornography all the time
let me fix my list I gotta add that in
because that is that rampant that's what
you're saying can you unpack that like
for some of us we're not in your world
we don't know how bad it is all we do is
we either read about it or we don't read
about it that's the one right uh 26 FBI
ran website sharing thousands of child
porn images this is from USA Today this
one I was talking about 2016. okay so
the operations whose detail remain large
the secret was at least the third time
in recent years that FBI agents took
control of a child pornography site but
left it online in an attempt to catch
users who officials said would otherwise
remain hidden behind an encrypted and
Anonymous computer network in each case
the FBI infected decide which software
that punctured that security allowing
agents to identify hundreds of users the
justice department acknowledging court
filings that the FPA operated the site
known as playpen February 20th March for
2015 at the time the site had more than
215 000 registered users wow and
included links to more than 23 000
sexual explicit images and video of
children including more than nine
thousand files of users used to download
directly from the FBI some of the images
described in court filings involve
children barely old enough for what yeah
kindergarten the approach is a
significant departure from the
government's past tactics for battling
online child porn which is uh instructed
that they should not allow images of
child being a sexually assaulted to
become public the justice department has
said that children depicted in such
images are harmed each time they are
viewed and once those images leave the
government's control agents have no way
to prevent them from being copied and
recopied to other parts of the internet
so okay this is this irritates and
frustrates a lot of different people all
you have to be is be a parent you got
four kids I don't know how many kids you
have two kids boy girl what's the boys
boys okay
I got four kids boy boy girl girl and as
a father you see this one you're
paranoid naturally the level of paranoia
goes up the day you have a kid but why
is there not a deeper investigation into
issues like this I think and he worked
it so he might be able to talk to it
more but I think it goes back to what
we're talking about with the stats the
FBI sees as a site like this and instead
of shutting it down and trying to get
into another site which they can do that
this says software another way it can be
done is if you catch someone who created
such a site and now you give them a deal
or turn them into a CHS and say give us
access and then they can take it over
that way as well but instead of just
shutting it down and moving on to the
next one to try and shut down the next
one they leave it open so then they can
get more users into the site so then
they can slap them with possession of
child porn instead of digging deeper
this is where you need your good knuckle
dragging investigators who are out there
doing the grunt work
because okay yes have possessing child
porn is horrible it's awful yes arrest
those people when you can but don't
allow them to access the site that
you're in control of so you can do it go
find the people who are producing that
type of child porn and get them the
users and possessors of it are going to
be able to find it so yeah it's it's
like whack-a-mole when it comes to to
possession of it but allowing it's
seizing a site and allowing people to
use it I think goes to that stat padding
and honestly goes to a particular type
of evil that the FBI is is participating
in
I think there's a cultural component to
this that
um there's not a lot of appetite even
from the public because it's so
egregious and gross and nobody we just
won't think about it I want you to have
your press conference where you put a
Dozen guns and a big pile of dope on the
table and all the money and say look the
FBI is doing a good job I I can live
with that as a citizen because good job
cops but if you start talking about
images of
six-month-old babies being sodomized
what I've seen yep that's not your
reaction right there that's not going to
be good for my image even if I'm talking
about putting it and that and that that
wouldn't want that job like I don't even
want that Vision I didn't want that what
a freaking job but it is it is a
necessary yeah I'm gonna stand the breed
yeah and I'm gonna do that because it
has to be done and we need to have our
lawmakers have the courage to stand up
and pass the laws that are necessary to
actually punish these guys and and look
the the laws for federal
um child pornography creation it's like
15 years for an image it's I mean
significant
uh who who show me the lawmaker that is
gonna say be a nay vote on Capital
charges for possessing or creating job
who would be though left or right
there's some judges that were arguing to
lower the sentences because it's easier
to access it than it used to be so you
should be that should be irrelevant yeah
what's the criminal profile of these
types of people obviously this is
absolute sickos but is there some
uniformity to actually who's watching
this child perform I mean for us it was
it was typically
almost universally male I think I talked
to some more experience the best cares
of me and they it was oh I had one
female it's that right predominantly
male age gen uh age race anything all
over it's you know old creepy chess of
the Molester guy down to 18 year old kid
who's just you know starts on that path
and and I remember seeing this
explanation for it once where he I mean
you don't want to be sympathetic to this
guy but he explained it honestly and he
said look when I was 13 years old I like
the 13 year old girls and then I was 15
years old and and it's just froze they
they got older but I still liked the 13
year old girls and then I was 17 years
old and then she was 13 years old and I
was 20 years old and she's still 13
years old he's like my preference for
women never Advance with my age and so
you have these guys who are 18 that are
dealing with that and then just all the
way up the Gambit and then and it's very
common to have the Hands-On offenders
that are trying to they they rationalize
their head well I'm not hurting a child
I'm keeping these desires Away by
watching it so I'm okay and that's why
you see all the all the time these guys
my theory is they have this red in their
Ledger
that they feel so horrible about which
is why they're doing all this community
engagement and they're a deacon in the
in the church and they're a little
league baseball coach I mean they might
be trying to actually find victims I
think a lot of them just feel so bad
about it that they think I'm gonna rack
up as many wins as I can so this one
blemish will be erased but universally
they all confess
I mean just because it's ones and zeros
for for one part they know they're
caught and then a lot of them just or
honest and they don't have a criminal
criminal background beyond that that's
it
but it's every it's they're true every
time an image is is shared that child is
a victim again and again it's always
horrible it's a terrible job to have
someone's got to do it you know uh it's
like the job where in the military you
have to go tell the family your son has
died nobody wants that job it's the
worst job and it has to be the right DNA
wiring of a person with a gentle voice
that comes in that's understanding
imagine every day today I have to do to
four people today I have to do two three
people today I have to do nobody wants a
job someone's got to do it
um gentlemen uh first of all I applaud
you guys for what you're doing it is not
easy to be where you're at I don't think
I speak for myself alone I think there's
a lot of other people that don't trust
what the FBI is up to uh that they're
wondering we don't mind having an FBI if
you actually do your job to protect us
and get the bad guy which is kind of
what we think your job is and if you do
that we're okay with that we don't mind
funding it and you you're seeing
nowadays where a DeSantis is talking
about child rape is uh uh is a death
penalty and that's actually creating
momentum it's like wait actually yeah
that kind of does make sense why
wouldn't you want something like that to
somebody who's doing this
and that's a topic of discussion for
2024 presidential election where they're
talking about these types of things
Governor Ron descent to signed a bill
Monday allowing for the death penalty
for child rapist setting up a potential
Supreme Court challenge the bill which
will become law October 1st makes sexual
battery of a person under 12 a capital
crime can you show the one with Newsome
what he signed I just sent you the link
on this one a new California law
protecting pedophilia is a vile uh this
is a couple years ago a couple weeks ago
Governor Newsom signed a law that would
allow judges to decide whether or not to
list someone as a sex offender for have
an oral or anal with a minor this bill
has been appalled has appalled many as
it should and yet some have failed to
realize that it is simply meant to
expand the discretion that was already
granted to judges in the past you see
stuff like this and it's it's so extreme
that you're like yeah this is not real
this is this has got to be fake now you
can go Google this for yourself and do
your own research as we're going through
this stuff but uh folks if you watch
this with these two uh brave men Garrett
boil as well as Steve friend who came
out to share their ideas and thoughts
and more of a long form where they can
speak freely I recommend you you give
this video share it with others and ask
them what are your thoughts on this give
it a sub give it a thumbs up and at the
same time go to Steve's sub stack I
think Steve you have a substance Garrett
has a sub stack that's called last
line.substack.com
that is his sub stack let's put the link
below for that and then Steve you have a
book that's coming out I believe June
13th true blue my journey from Beat cop
to suspended FBI whistleblower that is
coming out here uh June 13th in the next
uh shy of two weeks place the order
support these gentlemen as they're going
through this
phase right now uh and once again uh
fellas thank you for your work thank you
for the sacrifice and I got a lot of
respect for you guys for doing what
you're doing we need more folks like you
and I'm sure more people are going to be
uh from your background are going to be
giving you guys more Intel as you're
sharing that with the rest of us we can
kind of see that this is becoming normal
for them to be held accountable because
I I think specially an institution that
we pay their salaries they need to be
held accountable you and I are paying
for them once again thank you so much
for coming on to the podcast take care
everybody have a good one bye-bye
[Music]